good evening everybody
Tru makers staffs I notice we are
missing one of our members for the
committee I think we have to make a
style it's got quite a long agenda so
she'll have to join us sort of and watch
I think so good evening everybody and
welcome to tonight's East area planning
meeting Stratford district council my
name is Danny Kendall I'll be chairing
tonight's meeting in accordance with the
rules and procedures set out on the
inside page if your agenda tonight few
introductions I think from the top of
the table on my far right is a list of
Oscar from committee services its
traffic district then Mason ash who's
our legal representative to Knight my
left is Dale Barker he's our planning
manager and then we've got Neil
Hempstead David Jeffrey and Victoria
Chataway who are all planning office
here at Stratford district and we'll be
presenting various applications for us
tonight
so there are introductions out the way
before we go further just remind members
of the public please to make sure your
mobile phones are turned off or
certainly too silent that'll be
fantastic and also to make you aware of
the fact that we're filming tonight's
meeting so it is being live webcast on
the website and should you for whatever
reason which to go back and have another
look at it tomorrow it'll be available
for you on the website as well in the
next day or two right item one apologies
for absence please disclosure of
interests right I noticed some pretty
much all about committees tonight I'm
going to be stepping down from
proceedings if I could just ask you to
give me the item number that you'll be
stepping down from councillor Mills yes
thanks rich chairman I'll be stepping
down from application on 7 on the agenda
mr. chairman bar would be speaking and
on application on number 10 I've had
communication by email from objectors
actually on this application thank you
did we all have that's fantastic so
we'll note that for every on application
ten counts the fielding did you indicate
as well
just the item is okay so item 10
fantastic thank you yes cat bounce well
as long as we're chorus I've got to make
sure we are can succumb Thank You
councillor Donnell can you made it thank
you I will be speaking on behalf of
residents on application eight and you
also can represent the parish council
for that one as well as well yes okay
fantastic
right if there are no further
declarations of interest
do I have your do you agree that I can
sign the minutes of the meetings on the
4th and the 25th of October thank you
I'll do that at the end I think I might
actually have to ask you vice-chairman
to sign the minutes of the last meeting
because each I had that one so make sure
you do that at the end for me thank you
all right right our first application
tonight this is item four found on page
17 of your agendas that's application
reference then 17 / 0 0 6 3 2 / ful
lodbrok farm lad but Road bishops which
in turn ins for the proposed change of
use of redundant agricultural barn to
holiday let associated works presenting
officer Neal hamster over to you thank
you chairman the application site is
shown on the screen with the with the
black dot now members we were this
application into committee on a number
of previous occasions and has been
subject to a member site visit which
took place on the 2nd of august so the
general location is approximately not
nought point seven kilometers so the
northeast of Bishops hitching ttan and
just looking at that in a bit more
detail there's a settlement of bishops
hitching turn there so the red line
extends the access to the to the public
highway up until the to the location of
the barn there just to point out a few a
few key points on the plan
there's a public footpath which runs
along the the access and then goes
follows just where the cursors going
I'll be referring to some residential
properties which are referred to in the
committee report which were in the
location there and that is the the
Chilton line just running across there
of which there goes over a bridge and
the access goes over under it just
through there I've got some photographs
to show that and just to give members of
context in terms of an aerial photo
again Bishop sitting here that is the
the access that I refer to the barn is
there and just looking ahead into the
presentation the photographs which are
coming forward just to give you some
context of that I've got one of the barn
and and a northern section of the access
which takes in the railway bridge which
is there and there I will refer to a
gate which is referred to in the
committee report and that is just shown
there so just going into the photographs
this is the existing bond so it's throne
built with a corrugated metal roof and
there is a concrete apron hard standing
to the front which I'll refer to on the
plans later on so this is the first
photograph which is the the bridge which
carries the the Chilton line so this is
looking north going upwards towards the
bomb and then further down this is the
the access gate that I referred to and
again looking north the importance of
those last two photographs is just to
show the access there and the existing
grass treatment now there is a condition
that has been referred to in the update
sheets where there would be a
recommendation for details if granted of
the surfacing to be provided reference
has been made to grass Crete in the
committee report and from this and if we
turned around looking South Woods is
approximately this plaque this area that
did the hard standing of the existing
access which serves the dwellings
approximately ends
and so this photograph just shows where
the the axis comes out onto the lab
Brook Road and members will be aware
that there was a previous refusal to use
the the barn as a permanent dwelling and
you can note the the the large size of
the cursor which was supplied with that
application now work has been undertaken
in respect to that and members will note
that the cursor is far smaller now the
proposed work on site is the access in
some parking areas which were are
proposed to be in in grass Crete there
will be existing grass there as we
maintained there'll be a 1.2 meter high
post and rail fence and if I can just
zoom in one of the key changes is a
delineation of this area here outside
which no further buildings or anything
will be grown outside to maintain the
the the character of the area so just
moving on these are some of the existing
elevations so the photograph showed the
existing barn with the with the opening
there and you can see the the other
fairly standard elevations in terms of
the proposed works to the bonds itself
there isn't any difference between what
was previously proposed to have it as a
permanent dwelling and and what is
proposed now so effectively the area
would be is approximately 29 square
meters not included in the the bed deck
which is to be included so it's a fairly
modest size which would consist of a
kitchen shower and a living area with
the effectively of mezzanine put in I
would imagine for a bed deck there in
terms of exterior works there would be
roof lights put in some glazing to the
opening which you saw in the photograph
and some existing and some glazing to an
existing stone detail in the building
there and a new roof put on chairman
there are three updates as detailed
detailed in the update sheet which
includes confirmation of the size of the
floor space which so I've referred to
and changes to some of the proposed
conditions chairman the recommendation
is to grant plan information with the
conditions and notes as detailed in the
committee report and in the update sheet
thank you thank you know right our first
speaker on this one councillor Wilson
and counsel Doug more from bishops it
Chintan parish council hello welcome
both so you have three minutes between
you do you both intend to speak or what
are you here for just questions or okay
so yeah okay good just I'm sure you're
not don't worry so you've got three
minutes
if you remain seated for any questions
at the end and I'll give you a warning
in the last ten seconds if that's okay
all right over to you of course we've
got this of course fantastic if you'd
press the button in the middle so we can
have the microphone on thank you / - you
too permanent material harm and
residents in particular their privacy
the harmful impact on the social amenity
character and ultimate safety of the
neighborhood we have been informed that
residents of words Lane have not
received their site notices from the
applicants agent and accordingly bring
this to your attention our objection is
the use of the footpath SM 1 9 7 to the
site which we consider to be
unsustainable due to the negative impact
that this use will have works Lane is a
public footpath with vehicle access for
those granted permission by the owner
Follett's
this includes residents of works Lane
who contribute to its maintenance
country to the case officers report
which states the gate does not need to
remain open at all times
it is the landowner and
well who acquired the leg gate to be
locked at all times for safety and
security purposes as the railway is the
main line to London
it is not proven that the application
complies with WCC Fire and Rescue
requirements in terms of access for
emergency vehicles let alone
construction vehicles and narrow railway
bridge bisects the footpaths near the
barn preceded by a 90 degree Bend there
is no hammer head turning point or
nineteen point two meter turning area
this green lane links bishops attention
to Deborah's bridge it provides a
wildlife corridor and is a much too safe
local amenity for pedestrians and dog
walkers walkers between the settlements
from the gate ninety percent of the
footpaths surface is grass and mud with
an irregular camber horizontal plane and
widths in our opinion these impediments
will prevent emergency vehicles getting
to the bone may also prevent clients
getting to the barn loud but barn is
isolated nowhere near a public bus route
the only ingress and egress is by motor
vehicle or on foot a half mile walk the
proposed glazed frontage of the barn is
out of character and overlooks the
footpath if required it would be better
on the opposite side looking across the
Vista plan zero for D shows use of Grass
Creek but not the extent of its use an
additional entrance and gate is also
shown as a means of accessing the site
from the footpath and we question why
this is necessary the number of parking
spaces is contradictory the size of this
development only merits parking for one
vehicle are stated in the applicants
design and access statement there is no
evidence to support the case offices
statement that I consider as a holiday
let the residential use would be less
intense residents will enjoy nuisance
increased traffic and noise their safety
security and privacy will be
unnecessarily compromised when access
from the African zone land is totally
feasible if the committee is minded to
grant this application despite its
inconsistencies and planning objections
we regret the project condition be quite
specific by stipulating maximum
durations of occupancy on an annual
basis to prevent the development being
used as a residential
thank you any questions for the Parish
Council no that case it excellent
presentation thank you very much
okay we go to the next video got sue
Lloyd please speak on behalf of the
residents of works Lane objecting hello
so the same rules apply I believe you've
got slides as well so if you just
indicate to us when you want us to
change them okay so you have three
minutes if you'd remain seated for any
questions should we have one at the end
you just press the button in the middle
could I ask you just angle it down
slightly towards it not too far that's
fine and there's no need to speak into
it too much over to you all residents of
works Lane would like it noted we still
have not been served film or notice of
this replication certificate beyond the
plans is still incorrect impact on
neighbors policies state neighboring
properties and the character of the
local landscape we protected from
unacceptable impacts we're an
established community living in a
secluded and tranquil area of
countryside with no through traffic on a
single track we feel secure with a
locked gate providing a dead end and
Outsiders do not know we live there the
impact of tourists will be detrimental
to our peaceful enjoyment of our lives
safety and security will be compromised
by unknown vehicles day and night
increased traffic outside our home will
cause material harm to us and the
environment with extra dust and exhaust
pollution footpath sm1977 and will
further erode the unstable ground noise
levels will increase when lock-in and
lock in the padlock gate engines running
in car doors closing and if the gates
not secured there is a real risk of
trespass and anti-social behavior on the
land and the railway line reasons why
this gate is now constantly pad locked
councilor careful statement at the
previous meeting clearly demonstrated
this proposal was not a sustainable
development it does not meet with core
strategy the applicants age
also justified it was not economically
or financially viable as a holiday let
in the previous application which was
refused the impact on our community and
the landscape will be worse than a
residential dwelling as tourists come
and go more frequently and research
shows we have plenty of adequate holiday
let's the barns historic edge used by
Catalan of the wildlife should be
preserved developing the barn to a
holiday that with the material suggested
is out of character with its
environmental landscape and will be seen
from the highway spoil of you and
disturb the wildlife that live on the
site developments for tourism need to
support rural services this will not the
case officer tried to justify this
development meets with policy but used
assumptions not evidence it does
emergency access visit by an experienced
fire appliance driver access after the
gate towards the barn it's not practical
but because there's no hard standing
narrows in places with overhanging trees
and no turning circle appliances should
not be driven off-road it will not meet
access requirement for fire and rescue
vehicles part b5 and ambulances will
face similar difficulties we hope
committee refused this application as
your site visit will have shown it's too
small not practical or sustainable with
significant harm being inflicted on our
established community thank you thank
you very much any questions please yes
counselor fielding does the access road
access up onto the railway line for
emergency repairs they can just they
leave potentially fill it the railway
line comes down parks at the gate and
walks through they sometimes do have
their small vehicles if they bring their
large vehicles they tend to stay parked
at the gate councillors name is Joan no
good evening the young you said that the
road leading up to the proposed
application and is it not used at all by
any vehicles hasn't been for a long time
so so no farm
occasionally farms vehicle just go yeah
but very very occasionally okay that's
Perry
good evening could you just explain in
terms of the refuse collection from your
properties by nearby the gate what is
the procedure for does do you have to
bring your bins out near the gate and
it's collected with the big part so in
other words the the the refuse vehicle
can't come up past your properties alone
it goes to the end and it has to do a
big it turns about four times to get
round to come back out again we don't
actually have the large refuse truck
either they bring a smaller one down
because they can't turn the big one down
there are no further questions thank you
very much you thank you okay our next
speaker is the ward member councillor
kettle
welcome counselor you've had plenty of
time to prepare your notes on this and I
think so you know the routine you have
five minutes you remain seated for any
questions at the end over to you thank
you mr. shell just want to get the
machine to work properly right ladies
and gentlemen what we have here is what
could be described as a sensible
conversion of a redundant farm building
it is redundant without doubt the
officer reports and build on this
redundancy highlighting three policies a
s10 CS 22 and CS 24 persuade you that
this application has merit and is
therefore sustainable as you where the
applicant application is almost
identical which Neal was referred to two
previous that previous refused
residential application it refused not
just because of CS 15 but for being
unsustainable partly because of the
impact on the landscape cs9 this
application spite the officers comments
is contrary to CS 24 paragraph 3
landscape and paragraph CS 24 paragraph
6 relation to the road network in the
early application earlier application
the applicants agent the same one acting
on this application in response to a
question from planning officer ed Picard
made a comment that a holiday let would
not be financially viable that means
that Sears 22 economic development
cannot be justified as a reason for
approval
what has changed why is the impact of
this with a marginally smaller footprint
suddenly acceptable in the landscape and
now viable and accessible when
previously it was not I have concerns on
scale and setting this is a very remote
area access is challenging the previous
application was already refused on size
this property measuring three point
seven meters why that is about 12 foot
by about 20 foot is that an acceptable
design for a residential property
holiday let or otherwise we have clear
policies yes 9 assess 5 as does the MPP
F on ensuring good design and minimizing
the impact on landscape is circa to 250
square feet and accept
both sighs for property it has windows
main where there's only on one side
facing the London Birmingham snow an old
railway the railway is less than 200
metres way and on the other side of the
property the property has views on to
agricultural vehicle and engineering
recycling business otherwise known as
the field full of rusting combines for
those of you did the site visit
previously the scouts refused this
application on the impact on the colour
side
yep can then argued that a residential
development would have less impact than
a whole day let strange that that has
now changed that he wants to apply
rather they let I've also draw attention
to viability viability is fundamental to
farm diversification as I've already
noted the applicant has already said
that if I holiday let would not be
viable on this site how can we use
policy CS 22 as a viable diversification
when in the applicants own words he's
already said holding that would not be
viable CS 24 is seven points to be met
in this case C has twenty-four focuses
on the relationship to the local
settlement and the benefits of the local
community now what is the benefit of the
local community that would allow you to
approve this application we haven't
heard anything as how the local
community will benefit and relation to
that local settlement the only thing
we've heard is in the immediate resident
residents will have quite an impact of
having a notary Road they'd open and
there's a second issue here about
security when you live at the end of a
dead-end accesses fairly well controlled
there's a there's a padlock gate because
there have previously been incursions
onto the old cement work site adjacent
to here by both travellers at one stage
by an illegal rave that padlock was put
on the gate to ensure that could not
happen now how can you ensure the
ongoing security ought not only of the
local residents properties but also the
neighboring site which has got a history
of trespass if you remove the old
you deserve this is a padlock you cannot
expect holiday let people who have no
long-term interest to ensure that
security is maintained this is a very
small very very small building we'd like
to encourage farm diversification but
found diversification into a business
which the applicants already said is not
going to be viable is grasping at straws
I think we can do better than approve
this one those of you saw it on the site
visit I remember one comment being made
it is very small isn't it from quite a
lot of houses the entire footprint will
be smaller than living ten seconds I
think mr. chairman I've said enough
thank you okay any questions for the
ward member councillor fielding who at
this moment in time holds the key to the
gate is it held by the old cement works
at the other end or is it held to stop
you because who owns it and who has
access to is not really a planning
matter is it and I've gone to go try and
although I understand your frustration
I'm going to have to keep us to planning
issues for this one if that's okay did
you have another question yes if there
is a fire at the cottage and the holiday
lets our people are up there how are the
gates going to be opened I'm not sure
with respect to you counselor kettle I'm
not sure you are really in a position to
answer that question
being that you unless you're
moonlighting as a fireman I'm not sure
you are can I suggest we come back back
to that one is a point for clarification
if that's okay do we have any other
questions for the ward member in that
case I'm sorry to cut you off there but
thank you very much your input should we
go straight to your points of
clarification then counts the fielding
if we put your question across if that's
okay as a point of clarification can you
give us a little
oh yes do you have any additional
information on the access in terms of
emergency units the same thing go
microphone please College Council and
the independent object to mention the
fire brigade and on page 22 504 no
objections subjected development
complying with guidelines they datum
building regulations prove document B
which I have before me access for upon
compliance to within four to five
minutes of all points within the
dwelling days
thank you Karen I mean in terms of the
fire and rescue issue
you're quite counselor is referred to in
the in the committee report and it talks
about I'll read it out it's probably the
easiest thing WCC Fire and Rescue have
being consulted as part of the
application and have responded to advise
that should plan commission be granted
the proposals would require building
regulation approval and measures at that
stage would need to address fire safety
within the building including a means of
escape and fire suppression or a turning
area for a fire vehicle would be
required alongside the building it is
anticipated given the location of the
site that the applet the applicant would
seek to ensure on-site fire safety
measures were installed through the
building regulations approval so
effectively what they what they would be
seeking to do is have fire suppression
within that building itself rather than
rely on a fire engine coming up that
drive to reach it I think that that
would actually be dealt with under the
building regulations councilor yes Perry
yes I just wonder whether the officer
can explain just to give me some greater
clarity as to obviously the previous
application was reviewed as being
unsustainable can they advise why they
now feel the building is sustainable I
would welcome some clarity on that thank
you thank you I think I think the key
issue and the key difference is that
previously the proposal was for a
permanent residential dwelling now that
is different to a holiday let and in
respect of a permanent dwelling it would
be outside the any of the built-up area
boundaries and under policy CS 15 which
was referred to in the in the decision
notice it was considered to be
unsustainable given its location which
which is remoting within the countryside
I think the key difference here is now
the use has changed and it's a holiday
let then under policy is 10 and CS 24
that recognizes that both of uses in the
open countryside subject to other
criteria are appropriate so that is the
key difference in terms of assessing the
sustainability against those particular
policies what sorry if I just come back
to you on that point if I mean I happen
to have two holiday lets and they're
occupied for over forty four weeks a
year
okay would if this was a holiday let and
it was occupied for as many weeks per
year would that not actually equate to
the same toing and froing as a
residential it would be almost the same
as being its occupancy in terms of
sustainability or that just gets
disregarded
it's it's not a case of it being
disregarded I mean there will be
obviously that we doing and I'm frying
it's it's looking at the use per se
really in terms of assessing that
because that that's why the permanent
residential dwelling it's it's contrary
to the policy and that in terms of that
location the the holiday let in terms of
you know a tourist facility that is
viewed very differently and that's
looked in terms of policy a s10 and CS
24 and that that's the key difference
there will still be movements associated
with it but it's it's it's the nuance of
those different uses of that recessed
okay thank you
I'm gonna go through a number of
questions I've got counts of Crump next
and I know the other people that's okay
I don't know where that counts the
Perry's didn't copy a mine and I'll
being in their homework but very similar
questions one was about the
sustainability but mine's going on a
little bit further about the letting
what we've got any details of would it
be that is it what will be closed
what's the proposed letting periods and
can we potentially limit those letting
periods if we're not happy that it's
gonna be open 52 weeks here and then
I've got another question normally okay
I haven't got details of what the the
proposed letting periods would be I mean
in terms of detailing that we we have
got a a condition that is applied to
these types of permissions
should it be granted and and I can I can
read it to you it says the development
here by approve should only be used for
holiday accommodation purposes and not
for any other residential use falling
within Class C 3 the Town & Country
Planning Act and any other residential
use would include a personal person's
main residence or poem
residential unit of occupation it
doesn't specify periods within that but
that is the word that's the standard
wording that's used but good way if we
were minded could we limit holiday let
if members have a planning reason to put
that on then we could yes another
question is as mentioned both by the
price council and to avoid that the
certificates have been served on the
psalmist said that properly on the
psalmist said that said I just wonder
what the implications were regarding
that yeah I think well I think we're
just checking there for you you know
we'll come back to you on that
got these one chair but looking at the
document - has given me it does appear
that whether they've actually been
served directly they've actually been
served because there have been interest
by say a resident who was actually on
acting on their behalf so at some time
under the actual certificate ownership
process that have been served
it is a difficult one to explain but in
our view the way we construe that they
have been served at notice either by
actual notice or by word of mouth okay
counsel not sure if you're happy with
that will have to move through that is
that okay as much as I can or their
accounts the fielding than councillor
O'Donnell and you're back okay still
doesn't answer the question which I'm
concerned about is a locked gate and a
property and who has control of the
route it's a private road as I
understand it with the footpath and has
the certificate does that make it clear
that the they have the right of access
over that road which is a private road
okay awesome it's not a planning map I'm
going to go to Mesa very quickly good
yeah just quickly share from the
documents I've seen it could be
construed very much that they do have
the right of access over that tract so
if they have a right of access over the
track they would have a right of access
or right to the key to the gate
countess Road Donal then council mills
in Quetta cetera Thank You chair I'm
both the parish council and the
independent objector mentioned their
concern of the increased use and the
state of the road who's responsible for
maintaining the road
it's not um it's not a public highway so
it would be it would be the owner would
be responsible for that generally yes it
would be the own but sometimes the
people have access rights along that
track would have to contribute to the
maintenance but I couldn't say for sure
on this one and it is a public footpath
as well councillor Mills sorry to skip
you earlier actually couldn't going back
into the letting the game you thought it
would be wouldn't you so Neil
theoretically this could be left for
fifty weeks of the year because I
understand you're good there's going to
be two weeks where it's got to be empty
is that right I got that wrong
um sorry counselor say good no in are
you talking about the same person being
in there for 52 weeks alright yeah but
understanding can only I found got it
wrong that the holiday let can only be
let can't be left for 12 months this
could be let for maximum of 50 weeks a
year is that correct it could be used
for for 12 months of the year was a
holiday let there's no reason why it
couldn't I think if you had the same
person in there and they were using that
continually then you'd be looking at
more of a pone of residents but you can
use it for 12 months as the year as a
holiday let yes if that was the case the
planning our enforcement team at that
District Council would be brought into
the situation if it was being as a
holiday let out for a whole year
yeah absolutely and and that has that
solve issue has been investigated before
by the enforcement team so right so
there are ways of countering that later
if I made you at that point it would be
entirely proper for members to impose a
condition on the any permission that the
it wasn't led to any one person for more
than a certain period say for weeks so
that would deal with your permanent
occupancy condition looking at
thoughtful councils at the moment I
think you're all putting something
together in your head counts Lipari then
I've got council balance Thank You chair
um it was just all so another question
relating back to the previous refusal
where it was highlighted that another
major material consideration for the
refusal was due to the impact on the
landscape and character of the area can
the officer explain how the the change
the building is actually going to be the
same how this doesn't impact in their
view on the landscape
character of the area I think you're
absolutely right in terms of the
treatment of the building that it that
is the same
I think the key difference is and and
the concern which came out in the the
previous reason for refusal was the the
size of the the curtilage and as it was
used for potentially was going to be
used for permanent residential it was
the how would you phrase it domestic
paraphernalia you know washing lines etc
etc which could be in there which then
would change the character of the area
and I think that's raised in the in the
decision notice we're just just
paraphrases is due to the introduction
of a domestic dwelling and its
associated paraphernalia which is which
is what was mentioned in the in the in
the description and reason for refusal
coupled with the prominent location of
the barn and the subsequent potential
erosion of the rural character and
landscape so what the applicant has has
looked to do is significantly reduce
that the currently so it's far tighter
to the to the barn and also like that
the point that I raised during the
presentation in terms of limiting to
that area so anything outside that area
they're saying they wouldn't have any
additional planting or built form so
that's how they the applicant has tried
to overcome that that refusal in terms
of the character area one county
committee next to the livestock and we
got a rule on we couldn't be in there
board in this six weeks so like lemon or
carving or whatever and that seems to
work well I had believed that the
committee can make the conditions some
we've got to eleven months so we've got
different ones on different situation
gonna cut you off is this point of
clarification or know what I'm saying I
believe the committee can make the
conditions if you want because they have
sent and we'll come back to that in just
a moment I think we're about to move
debate anybody any other points of
clarification should we go to a debate
on this does anybody wants to start yeah
it's a fielding microphone please
precedent where enforcement are jumping
in when they've had somebody in
occupation for a month
even though the wording of the
documentation is longer periods my
feeling is that this is basically a
hovel designed to keep cattle out of the
wet it's in the wrong place it's too
much too much in the countryside unless
you're a railway fanatic Ora has pointed
out a rusty old agricultural thing from
the other point of view I don't think it
should be should go being granted
planning okay I'm good proposing we
refuse it I'm gonna have to go get a
second on that in a minute but perhaps
if I hold that off until we can very
flesh out reasons perhaps and see where
the rest of the committee are going with
this as well because that okay so if we
make a note that any proposal will come
back absolute an order later okay
anybody else I'm just speaking the
debate so I can't sleep Aaron I might as
well die Venus nobody else's this is
this is a difficult application I think
and I do agree it is the wrong proposal
and the wrong application in the wrong
place I have major concerns about the
impact on the landscape and character
the area despite very eloquent responses
to my queries in respect to that from
the planning officer I do have major
concerns regarding the
access into the site
you know holiday let's actually there's
a reference to the committee report in
terms of a holiday let won't produce so
much rubbish well I can assure you most
holiday lets do have an awful lot of
rubbish because a lot of them tend to
have takeaways and all that sort of
paraphernalia so the reference to in the
committee report that the the refuse
would be significantly lower
I've got concerns about emptying and
disposing of the the collection the
refuse collection are also because of
its location because of the necessity in
terms of health and safety grounds to
have that gate closed from a security
point of view you know with children
perhaps getting up onto that railway
line it causes another issue I also
think the sort of toing and froing of
traffic movements up to that gate and
the frequency of it also has a
disturbing fact on the immunity of the
immediate neighbors nearby but I'm
looking for some support on some
additional sound planning reasons to
refuse this so perhaps we can Quinn can
strengthen what I've my my
interpretation of the proposal in front
of the Crump I just refer to page 22
impact on the landscape in character the
area policy co-signs states that the
proposal should improve the quality of
the public Brown and hence enhance the
sense of place I don't think it does
there are only benefits to the community
and relationship to local community
again I don't think that's been
demonstrated policy CS 15 states or
development in existing settlements
as expected to protect and enhance the
character of the settlement involved in
a setting or in my opinion it doesn't
notice the parish council doors of the
ward member party eyes 10 states all
proposed those would be thoroughly
assessed against the principles to
sustainable development included in the
need to minimize the impact on the
character of the local landscape again I
don't think this does yeah can surprise
Tucson about the refuse etc and the
waste
we've also touched on about his point
seven kilometers and gives point seven
kilometers away down the track and I
don't think it's exactly the boxes so I
will be voting against this in order
which I've seen you I've got councillor
Mills then cats pants on O'Donnell
thanks for his chairman and I'm sure
this be a plan he's been suspicious that
the first one was turned down because
he'd be permanent now they decided to be
a holiday Lex I'm just suspicious there
but you know we don't know but some I
don't this can work you've got this
locked gate I know John feelings brought
this up if there was an emergency I I
can't see any ambulances or whatever
getting up there quickly
I think an Perry's motion about children
running up there right away Bank on
didn't think about that but now as you
said that sounds horrendous so I don't
think this is a good idea mr. chairman
thank you right board isn't making notes
counselor bonds thank you as I said
earlier I've got a lot of holiday lets
in my question this isn't an ideal
situation it will I think Harmon amenity
there particularly with the car parking
though it's going to be grass it's still
going to be cars they're in planning
reasons I think we've got a difficulty
in finding reason proposal my concern is
that if we do refuse it
that will do like a lot of others go to
a pail and then they'll go for a house a
permanent dwelling it isn't an ideal
situation you can put forward reasons
for refusal I mean I could think of
something for the amenity the just when
I deliver a baby at last Christmas big
Christmas before last because the host
ambulance was going to be 38 minutes so
there's the services for that sort of
thing he's not a plan in reasoning but
it does will have an effect on the
beauty if you light of the area the
parking and it will be an intrusion to
the neighbors Thank You chair I'm second
in councilor crampon councillor Perry
and actually counts the bars and
councillor Mills I have concerns
regarding security I don't understand
the reasoning with the sustainability
holiday let we would need to put a
condition on that because somebody could
actually rent that for 50 weeks of the
year and it's more less permanent I
don't see also how you'll easily police
that but it being such a remote setting
dealing with a lot of enforcement in my
ward for people whose holiday let's that
go over four or five weeks it's not that
easy to actually police and also I think
has a really negative implication for
the neighbors and it will impact on
their on their whole living environment
and I don't I'm not convinced about the
fire safety I don't you can rely on a
hot on when people in holiday light to
follow the safety procedures of fire
suppression when they're on holiday I
think it's really quite worrying that
both Londoners and a fire engine
probably would not be able to access
that property and whether that's a
planning matter or not I think we have
to take into consideration when we're
making these decisions Thank You
councillor crumble the second objection
and propose we go to the vote right okay
before we go to the vote I'll take you
as second in their proposal made by
Council of fielding earlier I've just
established the reason I know it's been
a good discussion we've gone around now
I think we've mentioned lots of really
good reasons I think we all agree that
we don't like this
that's we've got that far for me out I
want to sort of nail down our candor a
reason
refusal if that's ok I'm looking over
your notes I think counselor Crump you
did a great job in looking through the
policy numbers and I think if we sort of
start with those could you say are you
comfortable with those Dale do you think
that adequate grounds for refusal can
you run through them for us yes thank
you chair if I can second what you've
just said I do need some some help and
guidance to form planning reasons from
the things that you we've heard
Waardenburg a breeze if I can leap
instantly to CS 15 can I caution against
cs50 I won't be cautioning against any
of the other policies but CS 15 is a
policy that's looking at the
distribution of development across the
district and the section that was
specifically quoted was all development
at existing settlements is expected to
and then it goes on and the crucial part
of that of course is existing
settlements it's not development at an
existing settlement and therefore I
think perhaps that's not a helpful a
sentence to look at but that's certainly
the other sentences you're looking at is
9s - yeah again could you do you think
guide me a little bit on cs9 and
particular parts this is quite a lengthy
policy which particular parts of cs9 you
think we're not I was a crook along say
s10 and sustainment which I think was
probably stand on its own feet counsel
caught your seem tail page I'm just
going to catch
yeah I know that we've all so
pretentious
CS 24 is well it's a landscape as well
what voice were on the bed with our
numbers on the policies and I think was
we're basically saying that there is a
distinct area there the the character
and the space and the openness of the
area
it's tending to be quite dramatic here
urbanized if you
I don't not quite the right phrase but
bearing in mind it's a rural
agricultural area and then where Punkins
impact on the setting yes yeah so if
we're looking at cs9 its point two in
terms of the sensitive nature of this so
I think we're talking about the impact
it's going to have on the landscape in
the character of the site so that would
give me two seconds which is finishing
the paragraph is including it on
television
so in terms yes so for me I think and
correct me if I'm wrong wit we believe
that this is going to change the
character and the nature of the setting
in that it's going to change it from
being effectively edition well a gosh it
sounds about a dead end of a lane which
doesn't see much traffic doesn't see
much move vehicle movement and it's
going to change that considerably is
what we're saying and that will of
course change the character and setting
of the lot of the area so that's where
we can be wrong with cs9
okay fine a stems
do you know that way around this
hospital go on tango
Lovick
right so and in terms of this well let
me yes right don't count on is ten it
just has minimize impact on the
occupiers and users of existing
properties in the area
well it's going to have a massive impact
on them on is ten the second point done
thank you yep so we're concerned that
would have an acceptable impact on the
existing properties in the area because
there as a result of actually the next
point down which is the increase of
traffic as well and we happy with the
increase of traffic cuz I think that
one's crucial I'm gonna make sure like
to make sure we've got as much as we can
on let's make sure we're happy I think
in terms of sustainability don't we I
think we run into a bit of a problem in
terms of the holiday light status don't
we because of course the holiday lights
don't have the same level of requirement
in terms of sustainability I know we
make very good points about that but
we've got to stick to what we've got in
our construction in terms of
sustainability a holiday that is more
sustainable in this case isn't sorry to
interrupt chair go Fran I might am I
right in understanding here that we're
going for the second and third bullet
points of a s10 that's minimizing the
impact on the occupiers and to existing
and we employed the increased level of
that so we're looking at them and so in
terms of policy perhaps es 24 I don't
have you've got the copies on the front
of you but there's be the nature of the
activity whether it can be reasonably
located in a rural area so we're not
convinced this can be located in a rural
or not this rural anyway impact on the
character again of the local landscape
it's that backs up where we were with
the other policy and
the impacted character and local
landscape and the nature the
relationship of the area okay so there
be points one two three thank you
excellent just to confirm on that basis
I think we can prepare a reason for
refusal for your agreement chair
tomorrow if that's where you want us to
go okay committee thank you for bearing
with our original proposal was from
counsel field Ernie you content with the
reasons that we've put forward fantastic
and councillor Crump your content as
well as the second I think you second
okay
right proposed and seconded that we
refused for the reasons stated all those
in favor of refusal PAP show thank you
Rick right so the committee never
resolves to refuse application reference
17 / 0 0 6 3 2 / ful okay we can move to
our next application which is item 5
okay so this is application reference 17
/ 0 to 5 4 4 / ful this is jaguar land
rover gaiden test center boundary okay
bambi road gaiden and it's for the
demolition of existing store building
and a construction of an extension to
the southern design studio to the south
of the g.e.e.c together with all the
associated works is over to you thank
you chairman the application site is is
shown on the screen and is within the
built form of the Jaguar Land Rover site
so I've got some photographs which will
gives them some context but that's the
existing means of G deck building and
the design studio extension will be just
there on the the black line for another
point of reference is the British Motor
Museum just there so members just given
a bit context members will recall the
the permissions that were granted last
year for the Jaguar Land Rover site
which is the primarily the guide and try
your site there and the noise vibration
harshness building there's a an entrance
point going in here with associated
parking and under Lake and members may
have noticed that work is progressing
well on site at the moment so just to
give some context in terms of an aerial
photo this is G deck building here so
the design studio is this element here
the storage building is just along here
and there is an existing Bund which I'll
point out in some some other photographs
it's probably worth pointing out the the
existing building there you can see it's
significant in height and I'll be
referring to that later on so I'll just
show you a photograph looking along the
back here so there are three existing
works taking place to realign the access
road and do some works that existing
Bund which has been granted separate
planning permission so this is the the
building a question storage building
which is to be to be demolished and then
just look in there there's the Bund so
you can see how that's being re-profiled
with the fence and there'll be some some
planting on there and that will enhance
the screening of the the proposed
building the extension so looking south
so that's the existing building at the
moment that's the existing storage there
and proposed to store extension is to go
in there with associated plant on top so
looking west this is the the view that I
just showed you in the photograph so
that's the existing building to to be
removed you can see the the bum there
and again the two-story extension going
in there and the reprofiling which is
which is currently taking place and
looking east again the Bund you can see
the reprofiling and the the two-story
extension which is
which is proposed to take place so
looking at existing in proposed ground
floor plans that's the existing storage
area so you can see how the extension
will give significantly more more floor
space and that's demonstrated by the
provision at first floor level chairman
there is one update as detailed in the
update sheet which is a further comment
from from counsel Harris which is of no
comment at this time and chairing the
recommendation is to grant plan
information with the conditions and
notes as detailed in the committee
report thank you Thank You Neal can I
just quickly confirm this purely here
size of development that cereza referral
to committee that's correct
thank you okay should we go to our first
register speaker mr. horrible please
from Pegasus the applicants agent
welcome you have three minutes
if you remain seated at the end for any
questions and I'll give your warning at
the last ten seconds if that's okay over
to you thank you very much
my name is Owen Hollow and I'm here as
the agent for the planning application
and representing Jaguar Land Rover and
I'd be happy to answer any questions for
the invitation of the chair shortly as
introduced by your officer the
application seeks approval for the third
and final phase of the reconfiguration
of the seven divine studio the
application and before you tonight
follows and is consistent with other
recently approved applications or check
your Land Rover on the gauging sites
this includes the relocation of a
service roads and and the design hub and
to the north the site has as indicated
in the photos the application is made so
that Jaguar Land Rover can continue to
provide or can provide rather the
placement office space in associated
facilities for its existing war work
force to enable the expansion of the
realization studio into the current
office space the proposals ensure that
the work space available to the existing
staff are of a high quality and provide
the facilities needed to keep the
company at the forefront of their
business the proposals have taken into
account or taken to full consideration
highways
and landscape matters and concluded that
the limited impacts are acceptable in
planning terms at nine point seven
meters the two-story building is no
higher than other parts of G death and
comparable to that under construction in
the DML building to these in the context
of the existing built and immediate
surroundings to the development site
this is a minor extension especially
when considered in the setting of the
overall gaming sites the development
proposed would sit comfortably within
the Jaguar Land Rover site akkadian
being screened from used by the British
Motor Museum existing Earth Balance an
existing vegetation the proposals are in
accordance with the national policy
contained in the MTTF and local policy
by virtue of policy a s11
and which support the operation recites
together with other benefits to Jaguar
Land Rover weighing in the applications
favour we went there for support the
offices recommendation for a 3-volt
Thank You mr. Herold any questions
please yes cancer Crump just a pretty
quick longs to Horrell and obviously
very little objections or
representations to the first cat so we'd
like to see more planting and
landscaping I just wondered whether that
could be potentially accommodated so
within the footprint of the building
itself and there's limited or limited
room for planting and that as the
committee will recall from previous
applications there is extensive
landscaping to pose as shown on the
slide there ecological enhancement area
one an ecological enhancement area to
and between the application site and the
parish or the village of Caden and that
provides some screening as it as a
separation Thank You councillor fielding
what precautions you are taking because
my ward
includes Edge Hill and we can look
across to that somewhat unsightly
buildings that you've got over there
which thank God
trees are assigned to grow up but I'm
concerned because you had this car park
put in with high light lighting and just
trying to stop too much like too many
sort of lighting in the area too much
lighting up up in the area what
precautions you take
and so specifically in respect of
external lighting there is no external
lighting on the seven design studio
building here and so there'll be no no
additional impacts in that aspect
right so Donnell
good evening um just getting back
actually to count stack ramps point with
bishops which in turn parity Council
they must obviously feel that there's a
requirement for some more planting
landscaping what is the facility for
that with this particular application
did you say it wasn't viable and so in
this particular application there is no
landscaping proposed directly given the
footprint size but there is other
applications that have been approved by
this committee previously that include
landscaping which will reduce any
impacts this application would have and
to your knowledge is that level of
landscaping in keeping with the request
of the Parish Council thank you okay
there are further questions mr. hora
thank you very much now we go to our
ward member councillor kettle you have
to be making clear playing musical
chairs a little bit with these next two
applications so if you have five minutes
don't feel you have to use them all over
- right Thank You mr. chairman it is
great having Jaguar Land Rover
applications because we have a center of
excellence here and something that we
I'm sure and in my ward we want to
encourage and this is part of their
overall plan and I know Neil has worked
very hard on many many applications here
so congratulations Neil them move moving
this policy forward I have no objections
for this I'd like to see it go forward I
have two concerns which are not mr. ting
conditions one is just to ensure the
material sisters pick picking up the
council fielding comment about the view
from further distances and in fact both
of Burton hills and H Hill do look down
on this as does it look at and
[Music]
behind Ellington you all look down note
could we possibly put a condition on
just so the materials should not be
highly reflective on the surface so that
there is minimal reflective impact an
awful lot of buildings do not have that
that some of the earlier buildings did
and I think we should follow the modern
policy rather than the earlier policy on
that and in terms of the planting issues
which bishops and parish council picked
up yes there have been parking schemes
in relation to earlier applications but
this always been a slight concern as to
whether enough has been done and I would
very much like to reiterate bishop
itching appearances concerns here and
that if there could be any enhancement
there's none proposed here to the
previously approved schemes I don't know
whether that's possible Neil but we have
lost bands in the past with relation to
early replications this has no
ecological impact on its own in its own
right I'm fully aware that there is a
conservation conservation area being
developed between a meter between Jaguar
Land Rover and the northern parts of
Gaytan village however that does not
address the views as you're approaching
gayden from the Kyneton direction past
chad so those of you know the road as
you look right particularly at night it
is a very visible sight and some of the
foliage that is there currently is
reaching the end of its sell-by date
anything that we can do to enhance that
natural screening that is in existence
today will be much appreciated even
though it's coming through bishops
rather than through gaiden on this
occasion but in principle chaps I have
no because and ladies well I have no
concern whatsoever that supplication and
I think
Thank You cancer kettle any questions to
the world member thank you okay points
points clarification anybody questions
should we go to the debate nope
I remember when the previous application
came up and bishops itching to mentioned
about the planting and landscaping I did
ask about it
but because I was new I didn't realize
you could put it down as a condition is
it possible to backtrack as council
kettle I suggested is that something
that can be done something with his
request in terms of the previous approve
on the site and effectively the master
plan on the site if I can just zoom in
so effectively the application site is
is going in there so there's various
elements of landscaping there there's
the Bund which I showed you in the
photographs which will which will add
some some screening and that's being
repro filed and worked up at the moment
there is if you can see this this is a
an ecology area which was granted now
this is consist this consists of a
series of buns up to if memory serves
you might between about five and six
meters high we've planting on top and
effectively that is to provide a
compensation area to the works which are
undertaken on this site now that is a
significant size and with the the
contours and the planting attached will
add significant amount of screening to
this site in addition to that there is a
landscaping buffer going along there as
well there is an existing landscape
buffer there and that is to reinforce
now I absolutely understand counselor
kettles concerns and I have discussed
that with with Jaguar Land Rover and
details have to be agreed in respect to
that landscaping so that's something
that we can we can take on board in
respect to that so in terms of an
approach to landscaping and in the
context of this this application an
officer's opinion would be that there is
you know a significant amount going
going in and probably an appropriate
amount for that for that particular
development there's the other question
of course about the materials in terms
of reflective materials would that be
something we condition as well so or is
it more than other things conditioner
didn't order note that we could add
there'll be more of a request ensure the
materials a consistent with that with
the with the palette which has been
developed for for the sites a developer
a consistent overall overall approach
the the plans are to be conditioned
which will confer to the materials if
members felt and mote was appropriate
with that that could be that could be
added that's fair enough thanking you
should we go to the debate councillor
Mills thanks for chairman yeah since
I've been accounted since 2007 and seen
the improvements that have gone on
Jaguar Land Rover and they've always
been pretty good okay nothing's perfect
no but but by and large I think they've
done a good job up there as council
kettle said the old center of excellence
and I think they've created the area and
my proposed that we accept this officers
recommendation was chairman you don't go
out and do ii did i'm very pleased to
see the parish council here
arms we have sort of having concern if
there is any lights it's all on that
road that the Gandy can support in but
laughs would you do but that's the worst
thing so I only have to do that reduce
it thank you so been proposed and second
does anybody else want to speak on this
before
yes cats fielding can you put your mic
on pretty supportive of anything that
concerns me it's like pollution because
as we can it there's so much light
coming from that area we can limit it
all the more we can turn it down the
better I think it's a fair point but
it's not something that we apply to this
application I think it's a fair one else
to say I think it would be nice to see
more landscaping and future developments
and perhaps more of an awareness for jlr
to be thinking about that in future but
for this one I'm quite content with
what's been said should we go to the
boat
oh I mean everyone's happy with that we
want the note regarding the
non-reflective I'm I was just asking the
question I'm not convinced it's
necessary I think most of these
requirements are met already if I can
just comment on that I think it's
important that the buildings have an
element of continuity and if you start
changing the fabric materials for one
element then it's I think that you're
right I think accounts are alluded to
the fact that actually more modern the
modern parts of the development have
actually been much better haven't they
so it's the older elements the reflector
so I think you're right I think that
probably has been taken care of already
so no right all those in favor of the
application please show committee
therefore results to grant 17 / 0 2 5 4
4 / ful and deja vu like item 617 / -
sorry / 0 2 7 5 7 / ful jackieo land
rover gaiden test interrogate him it's
time for the installation of a fifth
floor to an existing temporary modular
building comprising further
office space scale of development again
and Neil Hempstead look to you Thank You
German we're back on the Jaguar Land
Rover site again more in the center this
time I'll just skip over these this
slide is just just referring back to the
worlds which have been I've been
undertaking and so I probably the only
references that the the temporary
building is roughly in this location
where the triangle development is going
so members may be cool
a temporary permission was gone for a
four-story building
I think it's December last year and just
to give members some context of where
that is on the site that is the building
that we were just talking about with the
extension it was just granted there so
it's further within the site and just to
give you a better view of that that is
the that's the building in question so
just to give you some bearing that's
where the extension on the previous
application was and that's effectively
within the boundary of the triangle
development so the building at the
moment has got permission until 2020 and
the reason it was required is it's
associated with the demolition works
which are going on site and the the
relocation of staff as I said before
work is progressing very well on sites
and this has necessitated perhaps a
speeding up in the in the relocation of
staff as demolition takes place in site
and that effectively has resulted in an
additional floor needed the fifth floor
is here it replicates the lower floors
where office accommodation is is
provided and the ground floors got some
additional welfare facilities such as a
canteen as well so effectively it's a
modular building and it would just
involve an additional floor being craned
in place until the building's proposed
to be removed in in 2020
so chairman there is one updates which
is an additional comment from
the Harris and the recommendation is to
grant with condition and notes as detail
in the committee report thank you thank
you okay okay first speak again same
routine over to you thank you good
evening as before my name is Ellen Hall
I'm here as the agent for the planning
application representing Jake your land
rover again I'd be happy to answer any
questions of the invitation the chair
shortly as introduced by officer the
application seeks approval for an
additional floor to an existing
temporary building in the center of the
Jaguar Land Rover gayden sites the
existing template permission was granted
in December 2016 for four year periods
and another post fifth law is sought for
the same time period the application is
made so that Jaguar Land Rover is able
to provide additional floor space and
for office during additional office
space for staff during the current
investment and by the company that
Gaiden sites these building work that is
placing a greater number of staff than
originally anticipated from existing
buildings on the site who need to be
temporarily accommodated elsewhere the
additional temporary accommodation is
necessary so the construction works can
cause as little disruption as possible
to the ongoing business activities the
additional floor creates a model of a
modular building of 17 meters in height
at the central decadence sites by means
of comparison the existing defects
building is eighteen point five meters
in height while that under construction
for the triangle building is 21 meters
in height the impact on the development
on the built form and natural
environment is limited with the scheme
being sensitively designed and located
to ensure that there will be no adverse
impacts on wildlife the landscape or
communities despite the temporary nature
taking into account the planning balance
it is considered that the proposals are
of an acceptable nature are fully
supported by national policy contained
in the EM PDF and local policy by virtue
of the policy a s11 criteria which
support the operation of the site the
proposals facilitate the development of
the Jaguar Land Rover site agaden during
the period of significant investment by
the company and as such we support the
offices recommendation for approval
thank you any questions mr. Harrell No
thank you thank you very much councillor
kettle your turn
you know I support this I mean I would
just like to make sure that there is no
gonna be no lighting on top of this
building but clearly it is going up
another story in connection with earlier
comments but no no no concerns of the
store of course if the council was
decided Ischl planting of the addition
that'd be perfect but thank you I shall
keep your timetable shutting up
thank you any questions for the ward
member thank you goodness no it's okay
Thank You council kettle points of
clarification on this one any at all
I'll just ask you to Vera but just
confirm this not there's no additional
lighting as part of this application
no thank you debate cast Mills Thank You
mr. chairman
yeah III I don't think we could do
anything to hinder this this forward
markets have jlr me and they you know if
we said no to this it you know we're
stopping people working you know and
people you know they're employing all
the time which is great news so I would
say I support the Ovilus recommendation
mr. chairman I don't like before has a
proposal thank you second I'd like to
second counselor Mills proposal thank
you
should we go to the vote all those in
favor please show committee therefore
results too cramped application
reference 17 / 0 to 7 5 7
chef ul on to item seven no I think we
say goodbye to counselor Mills for a bit
and you do this one more if you can just
do one more if that's okay yeah I'll be
useful okay right so this is page 57
application reference 17 / 0 1 5 6 9 /
ful this is for the land adjoining
walnut house the green little countin
and the description of proposal is then
for full application for the erection of
5 dwellings with access from Bridge Road
including all unzila and enabling works
there's only officer David Jeffrey David
over to you
Thank You chair as you correctly stated
this is application 1701 5 6 9 ful it's
the erection of five dwellings on land
adjoining one house little Kyneton
members who planning committee may be
sensing some deja vu this is the other
side of the site we considered a little
Canton in that committee we looked at
application 1701 for 36 REM that time
which was a reserved matters proposal
which was resolved to grant subjects of
section 106 for nine dwellings on an
adjoining part of the site and I'll be
referring to that as we proceed through
the presentation this is the application
site outlined in red it's adjacent to
the conservation area which is outlined
here in pink listed buildings shown as
red filled in on their members all know
that the site is abutted by a public
right-of-way in the green hatched line
this aerial view shows the site as an
open paddock on the edge of the village
little Titans extensive network of
greens shown here this is one house this
is the site we're concerned with today
and there's the neighboring site which
has an approval for nine dwellings this
is an excerpt from the Kyneton
neighborhood development plan it is
adopted since it's alongside our core
strategy as part of the development plan
for this area policy SSB for all of this
land outlined red here is allocated for
the development of approximately ten
dwellings this plan shows the proposed
development of five dwellings outlined
in red also adjacent land which is
outlined in green is the aforementioned
approval for nine dwellings land within
blue is within the applicants ownership
also this photo shows the point of
access from Bridge Road members will
note the dry stone off rubble wall that
will be the point of access into the
field on the right the gable building
there is garage and then there are
houses facing onto the greens at little
Kyneton the trees along the boundary
wall will be retained and the intention
from the plan is to bend this wall into
the development so it will form a
boundary within the scheme this is the
opposing view looking west along Bridge
Road the access being in this area here
proximate point to the sigh notice this
is a photo showing the view from within
the green that little kite and again
looking towards the proposed access
those buildings that we saw the gable
end of here the access will be here
members although the views from within
little Kyneton Conservation Area and
entering the village were referred to in
the case officers report this is the
view from within the site looking at
Walnut house itself their boundary trees
on either side and this wall here and
the hedge and that trees will form the
boundary near the access of Bridge Road
looking to the left you can see the
boundary of the western side the strong
tree-lined hedge the neighboring field
actually incorporates a significant
standard trees much of the time just
drop out to this presentation now and I
will look at a video from within the
site
sorry snot from within this site this is
from Bridge Road showing the boundary
wall the opposite paddock
from within the site now looking at the
western boundary looking across towards
Ridge Road and then the last video again
from within the site next to the actual
walnut tree which would be retained here
we see the western boundary of the site
tree-lined on our left hand side the
boundary wall and the treeline boundary
of Bridge Road all that house itself and
the treeline boundary with Warner house
moving across here we're looking now
towards the neighboring development this
land that has been tended to an
additional different fashion is in a
different ownership and is the land
which would be the nine dwellings access
off Tysoe Road for that the boundary
between the two developments would be
the public right-of-way this is the
property which neighbors the nine
Welling development on Tysoe Road the
public right-of-way leaves the site in
this location and continues along field
boundaries in a westward direction
finally returning to the original view
of the walnut tree
the application proposal sees five
dwellings arranged around a cul-de-sac
members all know the plot one faces out
on to bridge road the boundary wall
bridge road being turned into the site
as a feature through negotiation with
the applicant improvements to the scheme
have been made in the form of a link to
the neighboring public right-of-way that
probably right away will be improved by
the scheme adjacent and additional tree
planting on the western boundary to try
and satisfy the requirements of
neighborhood planning policy ssb4 have
also been incorporated within the garden
areas elevations are shown here for the
different plots these to be completed in
a natural stone and featuring a glazed
element to plot for chair that concludes
the presentation there are no updates
thank you David
excellent I said our first speaker there
I've got David Gosselin chairman Parish
Council and Ken put us as well please
this is the unfinished business okay
captain Gosling I presume we start on
you how you to split this time between
you are you going to be do most talking
or if it's okay with the council I
should do all the talking and then any
questions perfect that case you have
three minutes you know the routine over
to you just a capsule and get my stop
okay thank you Kessler's good evening
the decision that you're taking tonight
will have major repercussions not just
in kind turn not just in the East area
the Stratford district this is a test
case for most if not all neighborhood
development plans you're being asked to
consider whether a neighborhood plans
should be given less weight than the
core strategy or the nape of National
Planning policy framework neither the
NPP f nor the core strategy were voted
on by the electorate this is a different
document and we're confident that the
government never intended the NDP's to
be ignored and interpreted in the manner
before you if you agree with the officer
you'll be sending a message to all those
who told to develop their plans such as
well furred that they wasted hours and
hours of their time and it will also
raise the question of why bother to
those finishing off their plans such as
Wells borne you will also be giving a
green light to developers inviting them
to look again and see where allocated
sites can be considered fair game for a
40% increase in the housing numbers
determined by a plan this is not an
attempt to cap but to set agreeable
tolerances we don't believe that you
should allow this to happen and know
that as our MP Jeremy right the officer
is attempting to justify the numbers in
the application in front of you
by including another site that is
pending consideration as we all know
even after planning consent is granted a
developer can return and apply to
increase the numbers proposed and
generally this gets permitted without
debate so please do not accept the
erroneous aggregation argument when
forming your opinion you must look at
this application for what it is an
attempt to increase the proposed housing
by 40% more than allocated in a plan the
officers report invites you to balance
the harm which is identified as views
from the conservation area against the
public benefit as you consider your
decision this evening this harm and I
quote from the report is cautioning the
gentle transition from the historic
conservation area context replacing it
with a substantive modern housing
development the benefit is frankly
nothing there is no community gain no
public open space no children's play
area no allotments no affordable housing
this is unnecessary additional housing
at a location determined as sustainable
but for a much lower number
Canton already has 15% more new housing
the required under the core strategy
either in construction or with planning
approval so it's not a numbers game this
is housing of an unnecessary size and of
ill-defined material harm is identified
I would remind you of the potential harm
caused by ignoring a neighborhood plan
benefits there are none if this
application is granted intense in the
face of localism I urge you to reject it
thank you thank you take off with one
quick question and I'm going to come
straight to the parish plan it's
probably counselor question for you
counts of predators can you confirm I
wasn't at the last meeting so we're
talking about a total sight here which
is sort of this l-shape I'm guessing oh
and in your planten parish plan which is
fully adopted how many houses and what
was subscribes wording that you used to
describe that well we want you in labor
plan suggesting the neighborhood plan
refers to the number as being
approximately 10 thank you okay and this
of course would bring that site in total
up to exactly 14 correct I just want to
make sure we'd established that point
thank you any other questions counselor
Perry
good evening counselor Gosselin it might
be a query for councilor pretties it is
in respect of your neighborhood plan in
terms of the type of housing in terms of
size bedroom size and that sort of thing
did you digital research and did you
have a policy in terms of the type of
housing that will be required for little
Kyneton as a
two big coins and I mean it's well it's
not big kite and it's kind to thank you
for the question counselor we've looked
at sites and we've looked at the type of
Harrison that would be required within
the total kind and district we feel that
this development apart from going well
over the numbers forty percent more than
was allocated in the neighborhood plan
but also provide housing which was
unnecessary
we've had other sites where a four and
five bedroom houses have been proposed
by developers they found it difficult to
market them and eventually they've come
back and said no we can't sell four and
five bedroom houses school reduce it to
three but increased the number this
occurred on a previous site within
Kyneton so this could easily occur on
this okay
but I'm major concern I would stress is
the fact that this is a 40% increase on
the actual site allocation as voted by
the people of Kyneton policies that
referred to housing mix it refers to
obviously complying with the core
strategy housing mix but that can only
be triggered by sites that are more than
10 in number and therefore this site as
long as the attached site thank you
cancel bonds yes could I just have this
clarification of 40 percent is this
forty percent over the quota that is a
minimum quota for the village or forty
percent over what the plan your plan No
thank you for the question counselor the
plan has voted upon by the the
population of Kyneton stated
approximately ten nine have already been
granted on this site plus this
additional five make fourteen
so we're saying the fourteen is four
percent four houses more than the ten
forty percent extra for the site council
fielding you refer to in your what
you're saying but there was another site
close by you think that is more in
keeping with the
neighbourhood plan how far away is that
sorry if the officer could put up her
and show you it is to the exact opposite
side of which are you referring to the
nine or you're referring to in a
completely additional be granted the
green one last time that may come
forward there is one under consideration
it hasn't been determined yet it is the
other side of Dettol Kyneton between the
sports and social club and sycamore
court that's okay for your own
understanding that's fine I'm sorry
nobody else no I'm sorry because it's
not part of this application so it
allowed the question I think we've got
the gist of the answer but I can't allow
us to go okay so brilliant are there any
other questions parish council in that
case of gentlemen thank you very much
I'm sorry I can't let you go on thank
you
right okay we now go to the applicants
agent Steve Taylor please welcome mr.
Taylor I think been here before so you
know the routine okay so you have three
minutes over to you right with the
greatest respect to the parish council
there objection is fundamentally
illogical and frankly it's inconsistent
with their approach on other sites in
little Kyneton there are two allocated
sites in the neighborhood planned site a
in sight there and I said it's illogical
is that both have been allocated for
approximately ten dwellings but one site
is twice as large as the other so it is
illogical to expect the same number of
buildings on each site on the site the
north the parish council are supporting
eight dwelling
which is an under supply on
approximately ten the total number of
dwellings proposed for little kind to
these twenty now if this application is
approved this will bring the total
including this exciting green that was
approved three weeks ago to twenty two
which in my book is approximately twenty
so we when there objection to this i've
been baffled by it from day one and we
have made every attempt to try and take
on board their objections we have made
changes to the site we have consulted
with the chief policy officer at the
district council and in an email to me
out to the officer that he said from a
power planning policy point of view I do
not consider there is a conflict with
the neighborhood plan that is from your
highest officer now in every other
respect this application is totally
policy compliant we're not building five
hideous houses here we're building a
superb development of five large family
houses with a range of bedrooms from
three to five dwelling which again is
Kampala suppliant with CS eighteen all
over and no because of the thirty-five
darlings have not under obligation to
comply to that policy that we do anyway
there are no objections at all from the
public and there are no objections from
any other statutory consort T the
application is sustainably located with
well connected to the public footpath
that divides the two halves of the site
which will allow children who move into
this development to walk to current in
high school or cycle there I've
referenced in the report questions from
the neighborhood plan examiner who
clearly suggested that cap should not be
imposed on
allocated site as this is contrary to
the MPP F in principle ten seconds this
approach to numbers was was recently
upheld an appeal in councilor bards Ward
for the core strategy generally but this
applies specifically to this
neighborhood plan thank you well at the
time I'm afraid any questions please
counsel Perry good evening mr. Taylor
can you just stand advise the process of
consultation with the parish council
over this particular site yes it was it
was initially put in and there was no
direct connection to the public footpath
that bisects the site from the green one
that you were briefed three weeks ago
and this one so we adjusted that so that
there was a link to that public footpath
which is three meters wide and naturally
bisects the site into two hearts but
also they were concerned about the stand
of trees on the left-hand side of that
plan over which we have no control
so we additionally planted all the way
down the left-hand side trees that are
in our control so that if the
neighbouring landowner decided to cut
all these trees then we would still have
you know a substantial planted boundary
along that boundary and again we try to
address any other points that they
raised in terms of effect on listed
buildings and so forth and so on and
that was covered really by the fact that
the conservation architect raised no
objection to our scheme thank you mister
tale castle Barnes not sure my questions
been answered but you had that Bartok on
a number of meetings with the parish can
throw yes well certainly the the
applicant has and I've responded in
writing to any points that they've
raised during the process on two
occasions
okay right any other questions at all
mr. Taylor thank you very much there
should we go to our ward member
councillor Mills if you're ready to step
up and summers urbanist ask you to make
yourself comfortable for a second I'm
just going to delay us for a moment
council Mills I'm very sorry to have
kept you waiting
we're age 42 thank you you have five
minutes good evening counselors
I'm very concerned by this application
the officers recommendation and the
interpretation that kinds of
neighborhood development plan I would
try to identify identify each of my
concerns and as far as I know one of the
things that there was no consultation
with the parish council it is wrong to
include two other sites and little kinds
and as part of its justification for
this one one of these sites does not
have approval neither of them are built
out nothing stops either of them from
returning with the revised application
to increase housing numbers on each it
is wrong to compare the density of a
build on another site with this one the
two sites are distance apart and this is
the furthest from the center of Kyneton
the state the sustainability of each
location must be taken into account I
would remind you that little kind on is
writ referenced in the core statutory as
a local service village and scored to
the level which consisted it too small
to support any new housing and less
brought forward in a neighborhood plan
the kind to neighborhood plan assess the
sustainability and determined 10 houses
on this site nine of which had been
received where have received planning
approval the number 10 was not disputed
by the Planning Department during the
consultation period so the number 10
should be accepted by us as the planning
authority it is wrong to say that the
site is within the settlement boundary
and therefore able to sport housing as
an infill the site is on the very edge
of the settlement boundary this boundary
was redraw was redrawn with intention of
including the site for 10 homes it is
wrong to say that this application to
increase the numbers on an allocated
site by 40% is part of acceptable
moderate growth the kinds of
Neighborhood Development Plan is already
delivering 50% more than the numbers in
village through the core strategy and
further development is an
faded it is wrong to say that it won the
site and little kind is being developed
for fewer homes than the plan and
anticipated then this site can be soak
up the ship shortfall this site is
considered sustainable for ten houses by
the people who live here and who voted
for the plan a plan which yes in some
policy provides provides flexibility and
scope for planning judgment but when an
allocated site is specified for a number
that it is not expected that the
flexibility means forty percent that's
forty percent more particularly if it
impacts on sustainability it is right
that it would be some impact on the
impedance of the part of the village it
is right that the views will be affected
from the footpaths in the village green
it is right that you should decide
whether that harm is outweighed by the
public benefits as a ward member I can
find little if any public benefit what I
can see is considerable harm to the
democratic process the report states
that the officer considered delivery of
dwellings on an allocated housing site
to be AB notable benefit it is not for
the officers to ignore the kinds and
labour development plan which allocated
its site for space specific number and
to declare any benefit by ignoring that
plan and adding 40 percent or repeat 40%
more dwellings lastly it is wrong to
claim that this application fulfills the
vision of the kind and labor plan by
securing appropriate developments and
safeguarding against unplanned
development which may arise if housing
commitments are not met met on an
allocated site this is not an
appropriate development housing
commitments are already met by the
approved application for nine houses on
this alakay decides to approve this will
be to inflict unplanned development not
to safeguard against it
counselors I cannot stress enough how
important this decision about planning
policy and planning principles should
this application be granted I do not I
do know that there are other developers
who are looking at other citing cleansin
who would take advantage of this
decision and use this as a president
to suit their own ends I was elected to
represent my community as you all were
I'm a strong believer in the principles
of localism and if this committee
approves this application you'll be
jeopardizing its ethos and I believe
undermining the legislation which enact
it I too urge you to prep this
application the grounds of impact on the
views from a conservation area contrary
to their kind and neighborhood
development plan over development of the
site and unless you think that a
neighborhood plan the neighborhood which
has gone through a dimetric process is
worthless then vote to reject this
application thank you any questions for
the parry Thank You councillor Mills I
just wonder whether you can advise
obviously the proposed development is
visit being positioned as family homes
can you advise how far is the nearest
children's playing facility gosh the
newest Jordans playing facility would be
in place ballpark piece which is in
Kyneton which I would say is toxic Melia
900 meters away and then there's another
one which is further on and going out of
kinds and which is about a mile away
going back to the kind of neighborhood
plan was there anything in the policy
where you were looking at sites for new
developments where there was a
recommendation that a site I mean
obviously this site was if I'm right in
understanding what you said was
identified by the the neighborhood
planners for ten dwellings would you
have imagined that there would have been
a children's playing facility on the
site
I don't think I'm sorry I don't think
it's a question that's relevant to this
Africa it's more sub position really
isn't it
speculating on what would have been nice
I think we have it was a something the
neighborhood plan that's requests but
we're very played facilities with with
separate with proposals of this size on
this side no sorry Council Perry any
other questions please the water and the
councillor fielding their referral to
large 5 bedroom 4 bedroom houses are
there any other sites that you know or
you can point where we've where there
isn't the sales going through because it
it looks as if there's going to be too
many in the in the area I've got to stop
you I mean we've got to stick very
closely to the application we can't be
wandering off onto other sites that we
think are similar and things like that
so if you got a question on this
particular application fine but if not
have to move on I'll kill counts the
band's first then come back if you like
it's got five big houses well I think as
mentioned by councillor Gosling in his
submission on other sites we've had five
bedroom homes in and because they're no
takers of five bedroom homes so they
reduce them and of course they reduce
them and put extra housing on so the the
need for five bedroom homes is is very
very small in that area just feeling do
you want to come back then you keep
referring to the ten houses was that
both plots the one we gave permission to
last time plus this one
particularly originally this was posed
on the site the whole of that site that
was in the neighborhood plan the whole
of that site was it was B for ten homes
but then part of it was sold off and of
course then the applicant has come in to
put another four up five up increased it
by it that's 40% and has been said this
is approximately ten to me
proximate 10 is either 9 or 11 not 14 or
I thank you okay any further questions
on thank you very much councillor Mills
points for clarification anybody else
Lipari yes the the point for
clarification I would welcome is an
explanation why the officer doesn't view
this or or why this at this particular
application has been considered as a
standalone site rather than an extension
to the application because if the actual
site when the if I might the officer
when he presented the the site it was
the whole of the red area of this site
and the adjust that there isn't it what
I'm just trying to guess that has been
presented to us and I would just like
clarification why the the proposal site
is not being considered as an extension
to the - because to me it looks as
though it's the whole site was part of
the site allocation and to me
the application that's before us this
evening doesn't strike me as a
standalone site this particular slide is
an excerpt of the kinds of neighborhood
development plan that is ssb4 identified
for approximately 10 dwellings the site
that we've previously considered is this
in green where we approved an outline
application in 2015 for nine dwellings
with access oft ISO Road officers have
considered them as two separate
applications really as the sites are in
different ownerships will be accessed
from different roads the authority
considered and approved the development
of theis our roads separately and that
scheme meets its own requirements in
terms of policy compliant housing mix
and affordable housing accordingly we
reached the conclusion that the two
sites should not be considered case ibly
as part of this new application of the
Tysoe Road site on that basis we
proceeded with with the application to
this point I think the best answer that
can be given really that understand why
it's a difficult one to answer council
feelings in councilor brain I hope so
any archaeological survey being carried
out bearing in mind as Edge Hill was
foretold Battle of Edgehill was fought
all the way up to here and there's no
motte-and-bailey castle just round the
corner have have you require of the
archeological which pages
I think that the answer is no there
hasn't been as far as I'm aware a
archeological investigation for this
site as of yet it is something that we
could address well it will be addressed
as part of conditions I believe for
intention so one of the conditions
condition 7 on page 70 of your agenda
will require archaeological survey work
to be done to undertake and prior to
commitments of the building any
counselor brain obviously the site in
the neighborhood development plan was
accept or the whole site do you use the
word approximately 10 is that the word
that in the neighborhood development
plan or is it your word
it is the NDP policy SSB for residential
development for approximately ten
dwellings that's the reason I asked a
question of the parent well it's part of
the neighborhood plans wording to the
question to say okay Council page 63
obviously we've touched on the two sides
saying approximately ten on both did ten
in ten making twenty this one site we're
now up to potentially 14 and then the
other site has an application in which
could have potentially AIDS
we usually compare or look at each side
on its merit and why I'm looking at is
that yes they potentially are site an
application of aid but there's no
guarantee that when it comes to
committee that would stick to the eight
and they could potentially have ten
orbitec C 12 because that's
approximately ten
on the basis of a sorry um so in if it
came to it if I put in twelve and we've
got fourteen here without 26 against the
application of twenty so that would be
so I'm just hey I'm just trying to find
a link between the two sides because we
normally come we normally look at them
on their own merits and on the
application that we've got in front of
us and there's an element of doubt
regarding the other side yeah I think I
understand where you're coming from and
I think that the first thing to point
out is just a point of clarification
about the comments on page 63 they're
not this officers comments they're
comments from the head of district
councils policy team I think what what
he's trying to describe here is that the
NDP the development plan as a whole
including our core strategy need needs
to be read as a whole and that there is
within documents flexibility I think
it's clear that the inspector on these
sites didn't know precisely in design
terms what was going to be the correct
number and that this would emerge
through development proposals coming
forward you're absolutely right
proposals may come forward down the line
for a greater number of dwellings on
these sites and we would need to
consider those on their merits your
investment can go up as well as down
it's there's possibility as well that
fewer dwellings could be proposed or
eventually delivered on any one of these
sites because what we're talking about
is commitments that have been made
through planning permissions or
proposals which are in the pipeline for
both of these sites none of them are
on-site delivering at the moment but
what I think that the policy manager was
trying to
at least a son was really that this is a
whole of plan assessment that there is
flexibility within the NDP sufficient to
suggest that this proposal on its own
does not conflict with that plan
necessarily counselor fielding just a
quick one the word stone you are using
local stone as opposed to mixed concrete
stone good question can we were talking
about this earlier there's new plans for
how this works so could you just talk us
through them so before the applicant to
propose the stone the planning officers
wouldn't wouldn't be putting it forward
but in terms of our assessment the
expectation for a natural stone these
days is that it would go through our new
process that was just referred to to to
get an approval over for a condition for
a stone it now needs to be consulted
upon with the parish council so that
they have opportunity to view a panel of
that stone constructed on site to
satisfy themselves that it's appropriate
terms of texture color and finish
excellent we go to the debate then
finished on questions council brain then
counts of and obviously chairman it's a
difficult one
I think the problem I have is that the
neighborhood development plan accepts
the development site for building and
the inspector cleared the issue we've
put an approximately ten so we've done
six to figure at ten it can be more it
could be less reading the report there's
no objections from third parties is from
the parish council and board member I
can't find reasons for refusal core
honestly so between a bit of a rock and
a hard place or listen to what my
colleagues have to say Thank You
councillor pants and
yes I'm very sorry for concentrating cos
Papa's been mentioned Long Marston
supposed to have 30 kids got 78 and
councilor Mills was here with the dog
when we were told that the numbers 14600
which we thought was a maximum is the
minimum so we are in the situation
because this was in the parish plan I
appreciate that it's more than they
wanted but they did say they didn't want
big asses well if they had to bedroom a
teeth later ten hours is there so I
think if we were to refuse it we would
have a job at appeal that's my personal
opinion I do feel sorry that we've got
them and it appealed now is that a
little bombshell there if you want to
put it that way too many but that
appears to be the way that the inspector
is going them if we were to refuse his
dog conscience we might cancel the brain
I can't see any real reason that Thank
You councillor Perry Thank You chair
I've got I've got major issues I'm
afraid particularly as someone who's
been involved in pulling together a
neighbourhood plan obviously not Kyneton
because it does send a large message to
all the the steering groups putting
napola plans together that basically are
doing all this work on voluntary basis
to think well actually what is the point
why do we both to do it this particular
if you take the whole at this site to me
it's almost planning via stealth because
there's no affordable housing because
the site's been split so they've got
they've got a situation here where there
is no benefit in terms of affordable
housing - to the village
I think it's a shame this one didn't
come first before the previous one but I
do have a problem because I do think it
you know there are serious questions it
sets in terms of the weight and and the
whole value behind neighborhood plans
and I have got big concerns about this
as a planning principle because I think
you know at the end of the day Stratford
District Council Planning Department
spent weeks in fact years guiding
Kyneton through their neighborhood plan
hours and hours and hours then they
actually ratify it and in take it out to
consultation and the first time on you
know this is not the first time because
the last time the the other portion of
the site we had problem in terms of its
design and impact on character on little
Kyneton and here we have another
situation whereby you know it goes
against the neighborhood plan policy and
I'm just scratching my head and thinking
it's not surprising but other villagers
who are putting together neighborhood
plans and the Secretary of State is
encouraging people to do made by the
plants what is the point what is the
point if you have a situation where
they've identified sites they've
identified the type of housing that
needs to be there and we just disregard
it hi doll Thank You chair um I
completely support what councillor Perry
has said and actually she said what I
was just about to say but I think we are
setting a precedent and I'm really
concerned about this flexibility
regarding numbers it's almost as if with
our neighborhood plans which do take in
an automat amount of time let's involve
you but not empower you well you know
put all your ideas down but I'm not
going to listen to a word of it
and I'm really worried about the lack of
weight we're giving to the NDP and I do
agree with councillor Perry
rather shady about this application
because it is just a large application
the two sites their next-door to each
other so you can't I know they're
putting separately but all they've done
is avoid affordable housing and
providing any facilities or resources
for that community so I'm not happy with
the application and also the signal it
sends out regarding your NDP because
you're engaging communities and they're
not listening to the minutes that I
think are highly dangerous way to go
Thank You counsel counsel fielding the
same opinion we've got a problem in tie
set where they're trying to do the
development plan and it's causing all
sorts of problem within the village and
now seeing this which is a gain
affecting the neighborhood plan and I
can see theis they're turning around
saying forget it we've had the problem
with stone in the village we've had
problems on planning sites there and I
really feel that we've got to keep to
the neighbourhood plan otherwise what
the hell what sorry what is the point
anybody else want to speak in the debate
my thoughts at this point I've got the
utmost respect for people who have taken
part in these neighborhood plans as a
ward member here I you know encourage
people and you know bang the drum flat
and go on about them over and over again
and I completely respect the amount of
time and the amount of work that's gone
into them I'm also a big supporter of
trying to you know of testing them of
testing their strength making sure they
work and we have done another
application and in in kind and I'm sure
you'll be aware of it however for me
we're coming down to one particular
phrase and as a history teacher every
day I have to teach the meaning of the
word interpretation and in this case
we're going to interpret the word
approximately and that's what I'm
sticking out and if I was in a classroom
now asking lots of people what do you
think of this word approximately I would
get 30 different answers from those
different kids because they would all
have their own version of this so I come
down to what my interpretation of
approximately is in this case my
personal feeling is this
is approximately around ten it is over I
get that and do I have a concern about
the way in which the site has been
divided absolutely
would I have preferred it to have been
thought of as what application come
forward as on-site but if we're looking
at the overall numbers for this site and
if it was to go to an appeal later an
inspector would look at all the sites in
the Ville Clinton and he would no doubt
draw a conclusion that it is
approximately around the same number and
that's my feeling but I fully accept
that's my interpretation of this and I'm
sure everybody else will have different
interpretations of the word
approximately in this case for me I'm
gonna have to go with the officers
recommendation of grant because I feel
this is approximately right that's my
thoughts are you proposing I'm about
proposed that said that we grant the
application I would need a second but if
you'd like to come in first more than
having can I just clarify you're saying
that 14 is approximately 10 is that what
you're suggesting just around
I know it's well it's just a guess out
of jail card isn't it for and the people
to put through a greater number than the
NDP actually want it approximately is
surely one above one below but that's my
interpretation of it again this is
exactly where we're gonna run I think
that's too big a stretch for proximately
for above but it's got to be a question
of interpretation for everyone to make
and I think you could go for under and
no to be complaining we go for over and
yes we get in complaints but I think in
terms of this it is I could make I could
sit here so what would've been great if
the people at parish planners had fought
inspector on the assertion of the word
approximately make sure you did probably
but there we are where we are on this
and my interpretation of this is the way
it's a round on there right my
proposition here then is that we grant
I'd need a seconder for that proposal
otherwise I'll propose
can't counts the bounce do you second my
proposal thank you we're just gonna
check something
could we ask what's going on I got to
share with you the discussion there's
discussion about where the foot paths
lead to could we just get you to
indicate the foot paths that we're
looking at please with the mouse if
that's possible
we're just discussing I'm aware that
we've kept public and committee waiting
well it's a bit of discussion going on
in terms of where these two foot paths
connect up to given they're both owned
by different well they're both parts of
different separate applications and
that's why we're just having a bit of
back and forth here to make sure the
officers and Mesa are happy so if you
just permit us a couple of seconds
longer
we're gonna adjourn for five minutes
apologies to everybody for this delay
by okay let's get back to it okay we've
had a brief discussion of footpaths I'm
going to start with Mason if that's okay
it's fine Jer right the members could
stay with me the application is the
right-hand side which we the council
approved three weeks ago as part of the
application there is an application to
divert the footpath now the application
to actually divert that the order has
been made but at the moment that's as
far as has gone so it hasn't been
confirmed to protect needs to me
and then after that it needs to be
certified so get my breasts are coming
downstairs so basic elements where you
see the path on the map that's not the
legal line of the path where the legal
line is at the moment is the red line
which has just been drawn by David or
Dale so basically the footpath link from
this application we're considering now
will go into a field at the moment it
doesn't link to a footpath eventually it
will once the works are done on the
right hand side without the moment on
the left hand side that footpath link
will goes nowhere so that is a slight
issue at issue I have with condition 17
is at moment basically the owners on the
left hand side have no control over the
owners on the right hand side to make
sure the owners of the right hand side
implement that four paths so they can
link into it and then day will come up
with various thank you chair makes them
so the the situation we're in at the
moment is that we are being offered a
plan that shows a footpath link that
connects to the top corner of that field
but we can require it to go no further
there is every reason to expect that
this site here will be developed in the
way that you approved the last committee
if that doesn't go ahead for any reason
a larger plan so generally speaking as
best as I can draw it that's the root of
the footpath as it is today the root of
the proposed footpath is this green
dotted line here and the proposal is to
connect through to it like that as
you've heard from Mesa that diversion is
under process it's under way that
diversion must take place in order for
the nine houses that you approved at the
last committee to be built and occupied
so there is reasonable confidence that
that will happen if for any reason the
developer comes back with another
application obviously we would need to
put the same requirements on a future
application as we put on the previous
one but the footpath is diverted to
follow that route so the only
possibility that this footpath wouldn't
be delivered and wouldn't be available
to the occupiers of this current
application is if the site to the right
this site is never developed and it is
possible that that will happen but
office is regarded as a very remote
possibility so the advice that officers
are given giving is that a footpath link
can be provided but it's with that
caveat that if the development on this
piece of land never takes place it will
not be possible and we will expect an
application to come in from the
developer to vary the condition thank
you
so verification the plat the plan we
approved last time came up to the
footpath is that correct or did it come
up to the Green Line the path you
approved previously chair came up to the
green dotted line it involved relocating
the footpath the motion to move forward
but in my eyes
until we get a proper legal thing
because this footpath has come up with
the last minute it does need a footpath
but as far as I'm concerned I'll be
quite happy to 230 feral shorty
okay explained it basically the past
condition the past condition company
implemented then they will come back
with another application chair I think
David's just offered me a solution to
this little conundrum
if you look at the application at the
plan here and look at the blue land
which is in the same ownership it is
possible to go from this corner of this
site through the blue land to connect to
the footpath at this point here so there
is an alternative route available which
the owner can provide and which which
can be conditioned use using a Grampian
condition okay right I do agree with
that because actually we could actually
do a Grampian condition because it is in
the control of the land it's not so much
I think well I well you've done the
right thing in bringing this to the
attention of the committee at no point
were the committee bothered about or
even mentioned the footpath as an issue
if we can continue to maintain the
footpath as it appears on the plan or
nearly the same as it appears on the
plan through a Grampian through a
Grampian condition then fine I'm ok with
this I don't think this changes the
nature of the application as far as I'm
concerned so I am content counts the
bounce I propose you second to the you
also
yes okay so it will be with we redrawn
in terms of the footpath which will
achieve this effectively the same thing
as we see it as is actually in the plans
its near enough it's that footpath that
connects everything up okay well we've
got a proposal to ground and it's been
seconded sure you just run it through
the boat and see what happens
I'm happy with that yes all those in
favor of granting please show all those
against and abstentions Thank You
councillor Crump
therefore I will use my casting vote and
maintain my decision the committee
therefore resolved to grant application
reference 17 / 0 1 5 6 9 / ful I expect
you'll be in touch with me in the next
few days to confirm various bits and
pieces thank you ok thank you very much
for being here you have to get away we
can move the Committee on to
applications don't move around it's okay
right so page 10-5 item 8 this
application reference 17 / 0 2 3 4 3 /
ful and is for 13 ships - Road all the
minister and its proposed extensions and
a new driveway access presenting officer
is Victoria I've got your name so I chat
away over to you Thank You chair this
first slide simply shows the black dots
as to the application site the second
slide shows in slightly more detail the
proposed location in the site as
in red and with the context of the wider
area this is a more detailed location
plan which also shows their access to
the proposed site which is to include
Victor access going into the curtilage
of the site photos in the future will
show where hedges to be removed to allow
this this is a photo of the site which
shows the site in context this is the
application site here this is the hedge
and this is where the proposed Vic Euler
access would be this is a neighboring
site this is a semi-detached pear the
site is has a narrow frontage which is
characteristic of this pear here on the
site sorry the application premise goes
the depth of the plot of the site you'll
also see on the photo that there is some
parking here this is outside of the
applicants ownership this is a photo of
the application site here and the
neighboring attached dwelling it's noted
that the the pear are not symmetrical in
their character sorry in their design
there has been an extension to the
neighboring property to the rear which
is approximately four meters in width
and is setback from the front of the
property there is however some
[Music]
attractive proportionality to the
overall design I would say and there is
some architectural detailing which is
characteristic which is that of gable
details
this is simply a block plan of the site
that shows the extent of the proposed
extension this is the two-story
extension being proposed here and this
is the proposed location of driveway the
main impact to the road will be on main
road frontage chip stone Road the
proposed extension is I believe seven
point six meters in width and would be
and the existing property is six point
five meters in width by comparison this
is view of the rear element of proposed
extension as viewed from the curtilage
at the application site this probably
better shows the proposed extension at
the site and the proposed serbians
designed into their application there is
a - observance to the ridge height of
the proposed extension and two gable
ends proposed to the extension with a
slightly more subservient rear element
here in addition to the the side
extension further additions are proposed
the existing canopy to the side would be
demolished this is a non characteristic
addition to the property also to the
rear for an existing single-story
lean-to would be demolished which would
enable space for a recess to be in field
within the single-story rear element the
overall proposal seeks to create
additional accommodation for the
occupiers which includes living room
space at ground floor and bedrooms at
first floor this is for personal
circumstances to the applicant which is
detailed in the application report and
this simply is a photo of the site has
taken from the garden of the applicant
this shows the
canapé to be demolished this is the rare
single-story lean-to that would be
demolished and this is the infill
section and this shows the existing
dwelling house and gives an idea of the
scale of the existing property prior to
the extension thank you Thank You
Victoria
so first speaker councillor O'Donnell
speaking on behalf of the Parish Council
in this case I believe you have three
minutes for this off thank you
good evening chair giving committee
ultimates to parish council regrets
being unable to send a representative to
speak in support of this application we
have read the report to committee
prepared by the planning officer the
planning officer and the Parish Council
are in agreement on many of the salient
points the extension would still leave
the property of the generous sized
garden in keeping with the majority of
other houses in the village the
residents of the adjoining house would
not be affected as the extension would
not be visible from their property the
house is on the opposite side of the
road offset far back with a wide road in
between and proposed extension would
have no impact on them in the view of
the parish council the only residents
who could conceivably be affected by the
development are the occupants of number
12 the house on the other side of number
13 and they have written in support of
the application the primary reason for
the recommendation to refuse is the
planning offices opinion that the
extension would not be subservient to
the main building as specified in core
strategy 20 this is the point which
ultimates to parish council wishes to
challenge the purpose of the requirement
that extension should be subservient is
surely to ensure that modest houses on
modest plots are not overextended
to the point where the original building
is either dwarfed or completely
swallowed up by the new extension and
the garden is reduced to a fringe around
the house we cannot see that this would
be the case with this application the
extension would be no larger than those
of other similar houses the building
materials and design
complementary to the main house and we
do not agree that any visual harm would
arise to either the character or
appearance of the existing house but
does not appear to us therefore to be
any compelling reason why this
application should not be granted other
than a strict adherence to the letter of
the law the parish council appreciates
that planning officers have a very heavy
caseload nevertheless they are concerned
about the way in which this particular
application has been handled
particularly in the light of the
applicants medical circumstances it is
our view that this is a case where the
spirit of the law should take precedence
over the letter we request that you
grant this application thank you
specially in a position to take
questions for the parish council are you
really so I think if nobody hasn't it
will move on if that's okay thank you
right we go to where are they Robert
Hudson please and Sarah bullying Emily
the applicants
good evening right welcome both mister I
believe you're going to be talking
mainly and you're abusive hit up some
questions I write it's fantastic thank
you so you have three minutes and I
believe we have to cite the slides as
well yes can I can I just
before we start blasting you actually
start on slide four thank you and we're
gonna go to Fair Kanter here so well if
you want to give us a sort of an
indication where you want just to move
on thank you that's great well you have
three minutes okay so thank you to the
parish council for their support and
labeling us to present you here tonight
after two frustrating applications
regarding imbalance number thirteen and
fourteen have never been balanced front
windows doors and layout all differ this
is easy to see for the river we believe
our design actually introduces balance
with driveways at the front and sorry
the following three slides show
subservience simplicity and quality of
design and visual enhancement the next
three slides show the minimal impact on
our plot we could easily fit another
family home home in our garden but want
to use it for family life instead our
plot is at least 25 percent wider than
nearly all of the other similar village
properties the ground floor design
requirements because of Sarah's
condition we need sufficient space for
wheelchair access in all rooms redesign
stairs to potentially enable lift in the
future and increase visibility of the
garden and the ground floor rooms first
floor requirements we need four bedrooms
two of which offer professional and
Families
support again as downstairs at the
sufficient space must be available in
all rooms for ease of access for Sarah
Post core strategy comparable extensions
that bring into question the application
of policy with regards to scale of plot
development include bond I to shown here
which was deemed compliant by SDC the
property itself has increased in
footprint by 117 percent our proposed
extension it's 47 percent also so
permitted on the same plot was a
detached 233 meters squared family home
practically the same as our entire
proposed footprint this table summarizes
the facts I appreciate how quite small
the detached nature of bond I was cited
as the reason for it not being a
legitimate comparable by the officer we
disagree let's assume that is the case
our second order means for example is
number 67 halfway house a semi-detached
property and once again as a family home
being built in its garden
additionally the original semi-detached
home was approved by SDC for a two-story
extension this inconsistency has left us
baffled our G diligence highlighted
properties with similar extensions with
number 5 closely matching our plans
shown in the next slide our proposed
development clearly requires significant
extend checkers but it's a need not
greed project instead it seeks only to
provide our family with a comfortable
usable home for us all we respect the a
to our house and wish to improve it
sensitively turning it into the home we
love thank you very much for the
presentation thank you no questions
thank you right back to our woman
Katsura Donald
yeah sure
okay so have five minutes this time over
to you good evening again I'm speaking
wholeheartedly supporting this
application the applicant is fully
engaged with both the Parish Council and
myself regarding this application the
three key points regarding the proposal
that I think we need to consider its
compliance with the core strategy cs9
requires that new development is
attractive and proposals will be of a
high quality architectural design along
with being sensitive to the setting and
existing build form which this proposal
certainly is now if you visit to the
site you would have seen that it's an
amalgamation of many styles with a
higgledy-piggledy theme to it
this proposal brings continuity of
design whilst also bringing the dwelling
into 21st century facility wise they're
currently using a camping low upstairs I
mean the facilities are not great while
the property is well screened for cs5
with landscape with that it's got a high
hedge and a fence the areas that are
visible from the road will be enhanced
for this design and therefore improve
the view of the property as stated in
NPP F it is key to take into account the
different roles in character of
different areas
recognizing the intrinsic character and
beauty of the countryside and supporting
thriving rural communities within it
aldermen today is a tight-knit rural
community and the applicants are very
well liked they're planning for this to
be their family home for many many years
to come
grandparents are impressed non-star and
their little daughter is at a local
nursery cs20 states that modifications
and extensions to dwellings can enable
homeowners to adapt their homes to
changing needs and improve the quality
of their lives without leaving their
communities and this council supports
such aspirations so let's support it
here the question of subservience is a
tricky one given the piecemeal nature of
the build thus far but they've gone
through design and tried to incorporate
a subservient roof height and the
extension has been stepped back and as
you all know from visiting or from
viewing the photos that even the
extension completed they will still have
a sizable garden room for a paved area
trampoline vegetable garden etc so it's
not over development of a plot as has
been seen elsewhere in the village
also of note is that historically as
Sean mentioned that it's never been a
matching pair of attached homes this
application is necessity not luxury the
application needs to take Sara's
progressive degenerative condition into
account and put bluntly her condition
will not go away she's not going to get
over it and it's just going to get more
challenging for her and she's very
sensibly planning for the increased
effort that will be needed to simply
move around to her living space in a
wheelchair as her mobility gets worse
Sara's not requesting that we fund her
own adaptations are indeed agree to a
walk-in wardrobe or a cinema suite the
basement of an ostentatious extension
they just want to simply extend their
home to meet their needs she's asking
for the space to navigate her wheelchair
around the house and the designed to be
open plan so that she can engage with
and be involved in family life and see
the garden and watch Daisy her daughter
at all times now you know in the future
she won't be able to jump up and join
her in the garden but as a mother it is
surely her human right and need be able
to sit and watch her they were also
having to consider space to accommodate
the very strong possibility of
installing a lift and the extra space
needed for extra care and support as
Sara's condition progressively gets
worse and finally I do have a question
for the officers in general I understand
that you have massive caseloads and I
sympathize with you as a clinician
myself I get big caseload problems and
as a result I suspect that cases can
become reference numbers rather than
families applications and the human
aspect of an application potentially
gets lost along the way but I do know
that the Human Rights Act 1998 is always
listed as one of the documents you draw
on when formulating your reports and I
would ask if you honestly hand on heart
believe that Sara's human rights have
been fully respected as his application
has crawled along and the extra stress
level she's obviously been placed under
I feel are completely unacceptable as a
clinician I have many patients on my
caseload with Sara's condition and a
good insight into the negative impact
increased stress can have on an already
depleted system and committee I would
urge you to please support this
application thank you any questions for
the ward member cancer fielding
I didn't get a chance to discuss it with
the applicant but the current house I
take it is too small and there isn't
adequate room for maneuvering around
with a wheelchair severe question
counselor fielding it's my understanding
that the current living conditions are
inadequate even just a stairway it's
difficult for Sarah to navigate and use
disability aides and this just simply
not enough room just isn't the most
needed turning circle don't you so it's
not adequate at the moment though any
further question yes the young daughter
who requires supervision is that for a
medical reason or just because she's a
young daughter no I think that's it
Sarah wants to be a full house or mama
to the best of her own I mean I think
we're moving into personal circumstances
any other questions to the ward member
please
no counselor double thank you very much
two points of clarification any council
brain there's any special circumstances
been asked for in relation to this
application in relation to the
disability chairman the-- the applicant
has explained the medical need for
extensions what the applicant hasn't
demonstrated is the medical needs for
precisely these extensions and precisely
this design and it's precisely this
design that's the problem it's not the
principle of providing for the
applicants needs thank you the other
point is clarification okay debate
that's the brain I think
German everybody should begin the
opportunity to extend around but if you
look at this particular property a
semi-detached character cottage I think
it's one of several pairs of cottages on
the entrance to older Minister which
year and this is not a modest extension
it's a large extension so it would
detract from the traditional 70 touch
character of the street scene in my
opinion I think the offices have
probably got this one right it's
unfortunate because I'd like to see the
family achieve what they want to do but
it's just too large for the character of
the cottage
cancer krump yeah Mt Airy topping us
what the the officer was trying to say
was there is scope and feasibility for
an extension which could potentially
satisfy the needs suppose that the
officer saying yes there's the
possibility of an extension but this is
not quite a suitable one that will make
an incision on and looking at the size
the extension when that's quite
tunneling as well I would tend to
disagree
often I think that we could come back or
it could be come back to potentially
meet needs the applicant and also
meeting the needs of the landscape and
the building and the the scale compared
to the overbalancing of the cottages so
no our tenth degree because the branch
this is not quite right so I can't knock
on support the application anyone else
Kelso Mills
yes thanks miss chairman yeah okay this
it does appear to look nice but they are
planning for their future here I mean to
put a tiny extensional it's not going to
be any benefit whatsoever and they end
up having to move away from the area
which won't do any good I feel it's a no
brainer I would support this application
miss Chen council Perry thank you I
actually rather like for design I feel
they've tried to interpret the gables
and bring and I don't think it's
actually over development of it there is
a large space to this property and I
minded to remind myself of the in terms
of consistency in decision making on the
other properties that we have given and
granted permission for I actually think
this is far more sympathetic but they're
recommending to use the materials that
will complement the existing main main
structure and I'm also minded on in view
of the special circumstances but I just
need a bit more a bit more thought but
I'm I'm minded to go against the
officers recommendation paid chef at
seventy nine shows the officers saying
the proposed site extension would give
rise to considerable visual harm to the
traditional semi-detached character of
the cottage by reason of its excessive
width which results in an overly large
extension out of scale it is a large
extension I'm not convinced that it can
it is considerable visual harm given the
way villages often develop over periods
of time
and I don't think it's overly large and
extension given the site of the plot all
the size of the plot I should say the
applicants make a good point in terms of
the garden the size could easily occupy
or could easily be occupied by another
house
don't sit perfectly but I think I agree
with counsel Mills counts up Eric Castle
fielding
committing a I'm happy to propose that
we grant the application do I have a
second second counselor pairing
my reasons has stated that I do not
think that it performs a considerable
visual harm to the traditional
semi-detached character of the cottage
while considerable I don't think it is
an excessive width and I don't think it
is an overly large extension my phrasing
would be in some ways it complements the
evolutionary development of a village in
terms of design style as well I think it
is well designed to the big but it is
well designed and it reflects the needs
of villagers over over the years it's
our villages developed sometimes they're
my reasons happy the usual set of
conditions too and I would agree with me
tomorrow of course I think removal of of
course permitted development rights okay
I don't think there's been a huge but I
think this is broadly acceptable in
terms of what we're looking at but I'm
not hearing that we really going down
that route I don't think are we okay are
we voting it against the office the
proposal is to approve the application
stones okay those in favor please show
thank you those against and abstentions
two abstentions therefore but against an
abstention therefore the committee
resolves to grant application 17 / 0 2 3
4 3 / ful can move to item 9
oops move around on it
Thank You chair this is application
let me introduce it sorry sorry
application reference 17 star zero zero
zero three four slash ful land adjacent
to the court poly world business parts
album be a reaction of five industrial
units including associated parking
inspector sir to include any necessary
enabling facilitating works over to you
thank you and apologies chair yeah this
plan shows the location of the proposed
units to the south of Salem and the
south of the existing units on holliwell
Business Park which is a site allocated
with core strategy for employment
purposes there's the application site
outlined in red access is proposed by
the state roads and Northfield Road
members of the public and counselors
will probably be most familiar with this
site because of the large test go
superstar there and its associated
pumping petrol pumping station there
this whole site identified here is what
I understand to be the last remaining
area of land within the Business Park
for development the area to the east of
the application site has a permission
for a fire safety and training facility
the area within this l-shaped band is a
landscaped area full of trees it
currently exists in which you can just
about make out on that aerial
photography there here we see the
application proposal included detail
will see that these five units and five
buildings are actually to be subdivided
into 14 units the numbering system here
is slightly strange because they've
missed
number thirteen so it says fifteen on
that one but there is only 14 units the
14 units proposed for within the use
classes b 1 and b 8 and would amount to
three thousand four hundred square
meters of floor space there's 64 parking
spaces provided within the proposed
development no unit has fewer than two
dedicated parking spaces but obviously
that the larger units have far more than
that this photo shows the point of
access within the business park to my
right out of shot would be the petrol
pumping station and the site extends
away to the left here behind these pink
hoardings again this is a view beyond
the pink hoardings
the boundary of the site running along
this tree-lined field boundary looking
left woods within the site rather
dilapidated holdings show that the
boundary of the site is along here it's
just rough scrub land at the moment I'll
just break to a video
so that's taken from the point of the
site's access so the adjacent building
shown on the right there this is the
site the land beyond pink hoardings
further down the slope will be the fire
station coming around to the Tesco
pumping station and then the neighboring
Business Park interesting that these
designs are what has been continued
within the scheme itself so just turning
to the elevations you can see the
proposed are typical for the Business
Park comprising modern functional
designs these are steel portal framed
buildings with each of them being
approximately 7 meters to the ridge and
eight meters sorry
approximately seven meters to the eaves
and eight meters to the ridge it's the
rear of the largest unit unit 2 unit 3 4
& 5 the committee report notes the
juxtaposition of the application site
with the land required for the
deliberate delivery of hs2 so this slide
shows that red application sites
obviously purple hatched area for hs2
not all of it being the line itself but
areas for cuttings and for ecological
mitigation and landscape mitigation too
but nevertheless an area that will be
subject to significant change within the
plan period chair an update has been
provided from environmental health
colleagues and this is described in the
update report it results in an amendment
to the
opposed condition number 13 which
effects the allowable times of operation
for these units subject to that change
officers are content to recommend the
planning manager be authorized to grant
planning permission subject to the
conditions and notes within the
committee agenda thank you thank you
David
okay go to our only speaker on this one
cancer got no issues with this
application certainly big improvements
to remove those shocking pink hoardings
improve the scrub and potentially put
some more screaming screening and sound
proofing when HST comes by as well so
this definitely benefits there we
definitely need to ensure our industrial
land is developed because whether the
100 plus houses we've gotta find some
jostle people are sayin I totally agree
with a construction management plan
because that area does get congested at
times and we've just had a road built
under Section 2 so might and around
about further down the road it's part of
the development of five hundred and two
hundred and thirty six houses and
sheltered housing nearby so this became
very congested but so we need to make
sure that sorted out I'm also concerned
about when the far Chinese service
builds their training area there again
we need to make sure access is not
impinge door in inhibited bodies more
than happy were the areas that have been
proposed in the update and the only
thing I would like to mention has not
been much in the report
it's that area and Alko Koba and
particular have had issues with newts
and so I that's not been mentioned so
I'd like to see some more investigation
about that course isn't that gone there
so I'm going to see whether I've been
protected and the issues on that so
apart from that definitely improvement
to get rid last shocking pink hoarding
improve the scrubber area provides some
noise insulation when I just to is built
wide in Lund for jobs job creation
sustainable so no particular issues and
we need to make sure we've got a
construction management plan the notes
yeah ours I'm happy with and no
impingement on the fine china and center
when that's built so that's me done
thank you any questions
councillor fielding in councillor brain
these are classified Astarte units are
they no I'm not started Eunice it's the
ones that well I don't think so the ones
next to it are more to use different
usage tend to be small the garages guys
units but there are some bigger
developments there as well so I don't
think I particularly specified is some
starter units okay cat some brain any
going to erase no objection an Assessor
ecological issues and I wonder what
detail you have debate the newts because
I mean it is an expense to developers I
just know that our cocoa butter of had
issues in the past but there is David
Putney report the nearest and they've
had issues regarding developing the car
park and extent in their car park I
can't remember the office that the lady
went on maternity leave is it Lucy no
there's Mikey was doing but alko kappa
was potential issues with the car park
and there was no I was just raising the
concern I didn't know where they've been
load up on us all right thank you there
are no other questions
councillor Crump thank you should we go
points for clarification calibrate same
as you
the alcove site that council court
refers to is this unit here which has an
adjacent pond I'm not aware of similar
features in in this site itself
interestingly that the land in this area
of the field here is identified within
HS twos regime as an area for an
ecological mitigation scheme to
potentially take on on newts
there's no concerns from the county
authority the questions points debate
council brain German this was there for
size of development no other reason
notations I would move the officers
recommendation subject to the conditions
on page 90 and 91 and the amendment on
the update sheet thank you
second counselor Mills thank you to go
to the vote all those in favor please
Thank You committee therefore results to
grant application reference 17 / 0 0 0 3
4 / ful we go to our final application
tonight
item 10 on page 95 is dual application
references then one for a full
application for listed building consent
this is 17 / 0 1 2 8 4 / ful + 17 / 0 1
2 2 0 / LBC - 17 Aven Cairo
Aven - Salem and is for the proposed
direction a single-story flat roof or
extension and roof remnants plus
additional drainage minor works and the
same thing of course for the listed
building consent presenting officer
David Jeffery Thank You chair I'd say
this is a proposal for the erection of a
single-story flat roof extension and
roof amendments 217 Aven Cairo which is
a unit within the larger building which
is avin Cairo 8th grade 2 listed
building that sits at the center of
Eyvind asset
it sits within the conservation area
close to other listed buildings within
the historic core close to view shows
that unit 17 comprises the southeastern
side of the building and would formerly
have been the butler's pantry laundry
and boiler rooms so this is the main
frontage of Avon Cairo our application
site is hidden behind these hedges but
it's on this South Eastern elevation a
useful point of reference is this
chimney here which will reappear in a
number of these images
that's the southeast elevation and the
front elevation of the building that's
the same chimney these large hedgerows
in closing the application site within
the garden of
the applicant what we're looking at here
is the southeastern elevation the
proposed extension would start around
here coming towards the observer in this
position it's the same elevation but
further along so that's the sort of
finishing point of the extension
difficult to appreciate in this photo
but there are buttress corners to that
existing frontage which will be
replicated in the proposed extension
this image shows the boundary between
number 17 and 16 with the existing
hedges and domestic paraphernalia this
slide shows the existing ground floor
plan and the proposed ground floor plan
to see the extension comes out just like
the over four meters he's nearly seven
meters wide the buttress corners been
clearly shown on the proposal they're in
plan form that rear elevation that we
were just appreciating in the photos is
shown here existing and proposed just to
highlight what elements we're
considering we have the rear extension
coming towards us here and then some
alterations to the roof on the corner of
the dwelling there to make it pretty to
finish
existing and proposed elevations shown
in greater detail here so we're looking
at Casa lating the parapets on that side
they're an extension which includes the
buttresses a detailed door and windows
to match existing elevation details
Southwest elevations
again it's para pitting being extended
into a castellated parapet and then the
extension repeating details found
elsewhere within the existing elevations
close-up of the area to receive the
castellated parapet again further area
similar there are photos continuing
their chair the recommendation is for
the planning manager to be authorized to
grant the planning permission and listed
building consent subject to the
conditions notes and reasons details
within the agenda thank you thanks David
right on to our first speaker mr.
Anthony islet please speak on behalf of
the residents
welcome and thank you for waiting so
long I'll just keep you
I almost said it's my pleasure place
right well you have three minutes your
rain seeds for any questions at the end
over to you thank you very much now a
Vaquero as you can see was built in the
1800s
and frankly little has changed in that
time it became a listed building about
30 years ago and since then not a single
planning application has actually been
agreed and is now divided into 16
dwellings which occupies is occupied by
28 residents where we had them each
resident as a director we had a meeting
of the residents and the vote was taken
on yeah having an extension done 26
people voted against - didn't -
obviously worthy the applicants so that
was an extraordinary meeting there was a
flu act like a replication to put a flew
into the through the roof about them two
years ago and he was refused and I think
just like to quote this said the
addition of a flu to this great - listed
buildings considered to be harmful due
to the impact on the appearance of the
historic fabric he goes on to say
although not now visible from the
neighboring buildings or the public
highway it remains important to preserve
the historic design of the asset
therefore the addition of a flu which by
the way is about three four high by 10
inches and as I would say at least a
dozen other similar items in existence
therefore the additional flu would
detract from its appearance and
interrupt views of this elevation
contravening section 16 of the Planning
Act well all I can say is if the flute
under a meter high 3/4 high by 10 inches
was refused because of that I would
certainly think that a building which is
240 square feet with a meter cast
elation at the edge a faux Victorian
idea should be looked at in the same
same
I could go on to say that there is I
think an issue with light into the
kitchen of number fourteen and there
could well be a question of light into
the neighbor with the 45 degree rule
although that is not shown on the plan
the LED flashing for the roofer number
17 is actually attached to the wall of
them the 14 so this would cause some
damage to the building there is a stone
arch which goes into the back of number
one again not shown on the drawing and
this existing stone archway actually
butts up next to the stonework of number
17 so any disturbance on that and the
arts ray would simply fall down the
boiler room kitchen they are which was
the original area this this type of
building was designed to have an area
that separates observant to it so it's
not designed to be made equal to the
left hand side of the building at all it
would completely change the original
concept so is supposed to be subservient
now I do understand I'm gonna have to
stop you there you've reached the end of
your three minutes you didn't give me
the ten-second I did give you a ten so
sorry about that a poetess okay any
questions please you mentioned that the
proposed extension would affect the
light going into number fourteen yes
superseded on the photographs are there
any other apartments that will be
affected through light or through being
able to see the extension well number
number twelve which as he looked at the
back of the building is to the right of
the applicants because it's not on the
plan we've not been able to actually
look to see if there was a 45-degree
thinking it would certainly I mean it
goes out I forget about six meters or so
so it would serve the effect light
coming in but whether it falls under the
45 degree rule we can't tell it's pretty
close when you had your extraordinary
meeting and the twenty-six directors all
voted
what was the main reason for them to
refuse the main reason was that
everybody that not everybody 26:28 felt
that this was a unique building that has
changed so little since it was built
back in the 1800s and everybody thought
that this is what should be kept this is
the building which you know because
we're worried that if I'm gonna have to
stop it because I think we've covered
the point already and I think I said it
sorry I apologize
councillor Mills probably same point so
are you saying that there are no other
applications going to put extension so
this is the freight this is the first
one to come in
no there was there was a I believe an
extension application after there was
listed building and it was refused I was
a different different so definitely it's
not it's not this number not number 17
are different owner it's got a history
but that's it
we're gonna look at this yes okay any
other questions okay so thank you very
much thank you
our next speaker is Deborah
dragwon am I correct and close man thank
you
welcome again and thank you for waiting
so long tonight as well right you have
three minutes I believe you sent us some
slides okay so if you sort of give us
the nod when you want those on we can
now put those up for you as well all
right if you press the microphone as
well as button in the middle you've got
three minutes over to you
good evening mr. chairman and members of
the committee I'm Debra Bronwyn of
knotty more of seventy nathan cara and
i'm here this evening to support my
planning application for a kitchen diner
extension well I brought my house I was
concerned about the size of the kitchen
and spoke to the developer about it he
suggested I buy number 18 undeveloped or
extend I did consider buying number 18
I've wanted to extend for many years but
especially now as my husband's health
has deteriorated following his stroke
heart attack and his hereditary are
fighters of the knees a kitchen dining
extension with disabled access will make
such a difference to our lives and give
us room to live comfortably
I had several meetings with the planning
department and consulted the then
conservation of them
mr. Marshall who kindly sketched a
design you will accept except to help me
unfortunately I had to put my plans on
hold while my house is not listed I'm
well aware that the rest of the house is
a great tool list of building or special
interests so I employed an architect and
started again I sent my plans to my
neighbors and asked for their comments I
was horrified when I found out they they
had had an extraordinary meeting and
were determined to object to my plans I
immediately apologized and promised to
reduce my aspirations I wanted my house
to harmonize and blend in with the main
house so I consulted mr. Parker
delivered the new conservation officer
each time I produced a set of plans I
shared them with my neighbors and
invited their comments I never did get
any
after several discussions and
alterations mr. Parker gulliver's agreed
to mine now much retrieved plans with
particular provisions which I will
adhere to
I'm mr. parish council planning meeting
by going to a normal monthly meeting the
parish council refused to him any
comments from me as they have made their
decision
I eventually saw the comments my
neighbors had sent to the Planning
Department I reply to all their concerns
by email I later shared my comments with
the parish council and also sent them to
you we really need this extension I have
consulted everyone I could particularly
the experts to make sure I'm in harmony
with the historic format the main house
and abiding by the rules by plans do not
circumvent any planning grounds or have
a detrimental effect on the listed
building 10 seconds I will be most
grateful if you would look favorably on
my proposal thank you any questions
please for the I don't I just clarify
how long have you lived at the property
I'm the oldest owner I've been there 34
years thank you and when did you and my
husband become ill I made my husband in
2002 and my husband became ill really
ill from 2010 thank you further
questions
oh no yes thank you very much thank you
fielding
ah still switched on thank you um five
minutes over to you knowing that this is
going to be a fairly contentious
application both from the parish and
from the Cairo residence Association I
asked for a site visit I was told that I
was out of time the problem is that what
I was also told was every time you want
to put a site visit in you got to put it
in within the time limit is set for
comments from the parish or from whoever
I would like to organize to see a site
visit because it is a difficult one I
know one counselor couldn't find it and
I would like to see a site visit and
therefore put over to the following the
site visit well questions I was going to
say for the ward number can you give a
bit more reasoning behind your request
for a site visit what planning grounds
do you think that we need clarified here
well we listen to get from the first
listed building consent is one it's
difficult to give full planning but I
think basically the listed building and
also the problems associated with light
that were raised by the carrier
association very quickly I'm just going
to cut that I can in terms of describe
if you could describe talk through the
prepare the plan on the screen where are
we looking in terms of where are we
going to lose light do you think where
where are your concerns on that well
this is part of the problem is that
there is on one side you've got the wall
that around that window that you can see
in the middle there it's that is one
area where light will be affected the on
the other side I don't think there is
quite
same problem it is a small flat it's a
small unit and I and also along the back
a back wall and where it joins to the
nail to the main building I think
there's also problem with that area as
concerning as a flat roof and therefore
there is leakage then I think it ought
to be properly sorted up other questions
Calipari them caps melt or one of you
naturally council I know I bought it
bought everybody by saying visit these
sites I did visit this site you know
it's a statement ok yeah I don't know
how well you know the parish council but
obviously they've got ejected twice on
the original and revised plans and if
not turned up to voice their opinions
the chair of the parish council is
currently in Italy and I've just been
helping them with regards to the Aven
public save the village of board I don't
know why others haven't turned up I did
ask on the issues we've had that we've
had people objecting okay what member
objecting which is the reason why you
come in but when the parish councils
object if I project it twice they should
have the decency to send somebody or at
least send a written report to confirm
why they're objecting so I think that
missus passed on I don't know might be a
personal opinion where the committee
agrees but if there are no further
questions accounts the field I'll keep
to the procedure if that's okay
councillor fielding thank you very much
points of clarification or I think
you're going to suggest something else
unless we don't have any points of
clarification go on the council move on
yeah yeah I say I always go and visit
these sites and I got there and I
thought gosh it's amazing building I had
to say didn't realize it was there that
couldn't find the actual I would like a
cyclist I think would help everybody
would help the applicant and I think it
would help you know to make our decision
a correct decision because I'm not sure
I don't know how many in this round this
table actually visited the site there is
one online going up so if you haven't
visited the site I explained it
difficult to make an opinion account
very well my my question is actually to
the officers I'm very familiar with this
site which is unique
I would confirm it is unique a lot of
the units are set around a courtyard the
detail of the Gothic I mean I'm not a an
architectural historian but I all I can
say is it is it is I've never come
across a setting like this it's it's
it's almost like sort of the Warwick
Castle but more gothic with its
surrounding grounds the point I wanted
to ask the officers was a technical
question coming back to listed building
consent and particularly on heritage
matters where because the the report
doesn't
detail in terms of such an extension
like this how would the applicant be all
the Builder be able to match the stone
and that sort of thing but it's also a
principle of something that is such a
unique historical site in terms of its
architectural design where it's got a
history of having had refused I just
would like to some guidance on because
of the impact on the listed building
because it is a
is a significantly site of huge heritage
we have gone past the three and a half
hours time limit can I just I'm
proposing that we continue the meeting
till we're finished second thank you I'm
sorry to do this to you but cuz I asked
counselor parent to refine the question
for me so I would just like some
guidance and clarity with regard to
extensions to the listed building where
we've got a building of such heritage
it's stone building stone is available
that will match that there are masons
available who have the skills and the
tools to match the standard of stone
work that was previously used and I'm
sure you only need to look around
Stratford to see many historic buildings
the Falcon just down the road is
currently being renovated with new
materials to respect its its
significance as a listed building I'm
quite confident that this work could be
carried out to a my standard there are
conditions at the end I think they cover
that I know you mean right okay we asked
on tariffs occasion
just looking at my making machine here
he said yes so there's been several
applications over the years that this
premises if you can confirm so you check
yes I can't confirm there been several
applications but I'm afraid I don't have
detailed knowledge of their outcomes
[Music]
history of planning application that's
going to the debate more points
clarification councillor Dunnellon
councillor crown so can I just check the
the
see that we're discussing this evening
if that's not listed there was it that
part it was have I missed missed
something I thought the applicant said
that house wasn't listed thank you for
that sure the building is listed that
includes yes it includes all the
buildings in the curtilage it includes
the application site it is the husband's
personal circumstances I mentioned in
the application they don't form part of
the application
all right let's to go to the debate
shall we getting people want to talk
about deferral that cancer brain I don't
really have a problem with this one I
mean all properties that evolve over the
years it's a particularly property that
MP used to live up mister proof you know
if I remember rightly he's escaped or
bolt-hole after his affair the Christine
Keeler just sort of let you know that I
think the penultimate paragraph on page
97 sums it up
the officer I'll conclude that given the
existing design theme is maintained all
the external materials and fixtures the
proposed extension is modest in size and
will preserve the significance of a
great ruthlessly builded special
interest and then it's therefore in
accordance with the policies si si si s
9 CS 20 in the core strategy I will
support the officers recommendation I
will move that recommendation to the
committee thank you agree with you any
other people wanted to speaking it's in
date
you second of thank you if there's
nobody else want to speak in the debate
which we sketch the vote the proposition
then is to grant the application to be
proposed and seconded all those in favor
of granting those against
thank you therefore the committee
results I should say that was the first
application for the default I presume an
application that occurs results trip
around 17,000 0 1 2 8 4 ful I feel that
the reasons are the same for listed
building consent so I will propose the
listed building consent is granted as
well to have a second of event that's
the crumble thank you and all those in
favor of granting the listed building
consent and against thank you okay
therefore the committee results to craft
17 / 0 1 2 2 0 / LBC as well that was
our final I - tonight as a matter of
urgent business before we go can I just
ask for a very quick discussion model to
the committee in terms of start times to
these meetings it's been proposed number
of times that we move into unity with
the other committee and to start at 6
o'clock is now is this something we are
able to do I'd like to vote I work is it
so I'm in favor hands up those in favor
of moving to 6 o'clock okay those
against right there okay well I wanted
to be unanimous because otherwise we
don't have a committee that's going to
function properly so we'll have to come
back to that another time and think
about it so will remain at 6:15 start
kind of the comment on a different thing
yeah go it's a it's a Tom's though he is
really tom
I've had a dog buzzing all night in my
own age he's almost given me a headache
then he got louder toward